- Guys, if you haven't heard,
(upbeat music)
"Trash Taste" is going on tour!
Yes, me and the boys are
gonna be touring North America
in the month of September and October.
So if you live anywhere near
St. Paul, Chicago, Cleveland,
Detroit, Toronto, Boston,
Philadelphia, New York City,
Washington DC, Raleigh, Nashville,
Orlando, Dallas, Austin,
(inhales sharply) Kansas
City, Denver, Salt Lake City,
Phoenix, LA, San Francisco,
Seattle, or Portland,
we are coming to you!
All the dates should
be on screen right now.
Tickets have been on sale,
I believe LA is already sold out
and other cities are already
very close to selling out,
so if you wanna get your tickets today,
go to trashtastetour.com.
That is trashtastetour.com,
link's in the description as always.
(Garnt sighs)
(calm music)
- We are so sorry, guys.
- So sorry.
- We really, really messed up.
- Big time.
- A lot of times,
(upbeat music)
which you can now watch on our Patreon.
(Joey laughs)
- We do, we do mess up a lot.
- Yeah, we do, we do.
- For those of you who are our $5 patrons,
by the way, thank you very much,
you guys will know that you'll
get early access to clips
as well as uncensored and uncut episodes.
But we have extra stuff for you guys now,
monthly behind the scenes content.
- We fuck up so much that we
can make a whole new video
of just our fuck-ups
every single month.
(Joey laughs)
And we will present that to you,
to our Patreons on the $5 tier.
So if you do wanna go and
watch those, you can do,
but just for, you know,
'cause we've been feeling
a little generous,
the first behind the
scenes will be available,
you can just smash that link down below
to the YouTube unlisted link,
and you can watch the "Trash
Taste" behind the scenes.
- So head over to patreon.com/trashtaste
if you wanna see what we have to offer.
On with the episode.
- We always talk way louder.
Let me tell you about this thing.
- You beat your guests down,
and they're like,
(hosts laughing)
- It's like, "Shut up, I'm talking."
- "I'll wait my turn."
- Yeah.
- "Permission to speak."
(calm upbeat music)
- Hello, and welcome to
another very special episode
of "Trash Taste," we are
joined by another guest today.
I'm sorry, I completely forgot,
it's been a while since I've hosted.
- Yeah.
- I'm your host for today,
Garnt, and with me are,
as usual, the boys.
- What up?
- And today
we have a very special guest.
Now in case there is one person in YouTube
who doesn't know who you are,
(men laugh)
do you wanna introduce
yourself and what you do?
- Oh my God, that's a lot of pressure.
My name is Anthony Padilla,
some people say Padilla,
I'm totally fine with that,
but I do like to say
Padilla like tortilla.
(men laugh)
That's how I get people to memorize it.
Let's see, so, God,
how deep do we wanna go
into this history here?
- Your YouTube link.
- Do your thing.
(men laughing)
- Just admit it, Anthony.
- We have two plus hours.
- We have two plus.
- Are we doing two plus hours?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- Okay, let's get deep, guys.
So I started with my friend Ian,
I started a YouTube channel
called "Smosh" in 2005
17 years,
- What's "Smosh?"
- half of my age ago.
- Oh my God.
- Jesus.
- Half of my age ago.
- Oh my God.
- Half your life has been on YouTube.
- Half of my life, yes, oh shit,
I'm having to rethink so many decisions.
(hosts laugh)
I'm gonna need that two and a half hours.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then in 2017, I kinda
split off to do my own thing.
Been doing an independent channel,
which has slowly evolved into me
kinda doing deep dive interviews
with either groups of people
or one person that has,
you know, some kind of
popularity surrounding them.
And we drill in deep into the
psychology behind blowing up
or, you know, if it's a group of people,
I like to kinda get in
there and understand them.
I feel like so many people
have preconceived ideas
about what a group or what
a label or identity means.
So I like to kinda show that
there is variation and nuance
from individual to individual.
- Yeah.
- They're really good.
- Thank you.
- I mean, this is like pretty intimidating
'cause not only are you
like the OG of YouTube,
I can say like,
you're like,
- You are.
- you are like-
- It's not even like
a subjective thing,
- Yeah, yeah.
- it's like objectively you are an OG.
- You are the OG of YouTube.
But also you are now the
interviewer of like YouTubers,
and now we're interviewing you,
so I'm like, yeah.
- Just gonna reverse-engineer
this interview.
(men laugh)
- But my stuff is so different.
When I came here, I was like,
"So what are we talking about today?"
You're like, "I don't know."
(men laughing)
- We'll figure it out.
- When I go into mine,
I'm like, "Okay, okay,
I've got like these 45 bullet points,
I know we're gonna get through these."
I overplan so much.
- I think it shows
though, it shows though,
it's good it reflects
in the quality.
- Yeah, it really shows.
- My favorite stuff is always
the stuff that comes out
of stuff that happens in the
moment that was never planned.
- Yes, yes.
- And that is your whole show.
- That's "Trash Taste," baby.
- That's your whole show.
- "Trash Taste," baby.
- Yeah, yeah.
On YouTube, it'll say
top moment, all of it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- All of it.
- 'Cause it kinda hit me, when
you came in, you were like,
"So what are we talking
about today, guys?"
And we just look at each
other and we were just like,
- "What do you mean?"
- Ah, shit, we're talking
to Anthony today, fuck,
he's the interviewer.
And we don't have any
interview questions."
- I was like, "Do they have
some kinda secret thing
that they're not telling
me, some kinda prank
that they're gonna do?"
(Garnt laughs)
They're like, "Should we tell him?"
"No."
- We're gonna hit you
with a low blow in about 30 minutes.
(men laugh)
- Just grill me.
- Yeah.
- So actually, I've always wondered,
how much prep do you
do for your interviews?
'Cause as we've just
established, we do zero,
zero prep here.
(Anthony laughs)
So-
- The only prepping we do
is who are we getting on today?
- Yeah, let's see, so the show start,
I call it I Spent a Day
With, whatever the topic
or whatever the person's name is.
And at first, it was like four people
that I would sit down with
and it would amount to like eight hours.
Now, it's a little bit shorter,
like two to three hours
if it's just one guest,
a little bit longer,
but I do a pre-interview
call, which is like an hour,
hour and a half or two.
And then I work backwards
to try to figure out
what questions I'm gonna come up with
based on the things that we talked about.
So, (sighs) God, I cannot even quantify,
it's-
- It's a lot of prep.
- Yeah, yeah.
- What made you start
doing pre-interviews?
Is it 'cause you've maybe
had some guests somewhere,
you're like, "Fuck it, I
coulda done way better job?"
- A little bit of that.
It was also bringing on guests
that have really big stories
and I felt like I couldn't
just go in there and be like,
"So tell me about your childhood."
And then just like, they just go,
and I'm like, "I think they
probably got everything."
Also, I realized that in the interviews,
I was cutting out a lot of stuff.
- Right.
- You know,
I was like, it's a lot of me
trying to figure out where this is going.
I kinda wanna have an idea
of where we're going first.
And I realized that I was like every night
before the next day was an interview,
I would be up until 4:00
am, like 12 hours straight.
Like, "Shit, I don't know
what I'm talking about."
I gotta learn every single thing
about this person's life, like drill down.
You know, I interviewed VTubers,
that's actually how I found
out about this podcast,
I saw that you had interviewed
- Ah!
- a VTuber as well.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Callie, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And I watched that episode
and I was learning
everything about VTubers.
And I was like, wait, I
could just talk to them,
have them tell me the important things.
And then I could
reverse-engineer the questions
based on the conversations
- Ah.
- that they want to have.
- Yeah.
- So basically you take out
some of the research time,
where you don't even know
if you're going down like
the wrong rabbit hole,
- Yes, yes.
- And instead you
just come straight from
the source, I guess.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- And then I'm able to use
the extra time that I now have
during the interviews
to kinda drill in deeper
to like the psychology behind the feelings
that they were having and
what things affected them
from those moments and
how they affect them now.
And I guess it just allows
me to get a little bit deeper
with the conversations.
- Yeah, so the interviews
are like 20 to 40 minutes.
How much source like footage do you have?
How much of it gets
cut out, do you reckon?
- Yeah, so it depends the person.
Markiplier, we shot like
two hours and 40 minutes,
- Oh my God.
- and we cut it down
to a half hour,
somehow miraculously.
- Oh my God. (laughs)
- After it came out, he
was like, "Holy shit,
you did it, you bastard!"
(hosts laugh)
But we apparently were able
to get all the key components,
the conversations that were really meaty,
have 'em in there while
cutting out all the fluff.
And it's a lot of,
there's a big process,
we have five editors now.
- Four to five, wow.
- And it goes from person
to person, they all have
like a very specific,
they're like a specific
cog in the machine.
And it's a lot of just
like grinding it down.
It goes to the first person,
they get the full two and
a half hours of footage,
they cut it down to 50.
And then it's like, that person
- Geez.
- takes it and cuts it down.
And each person's really good at refining
all of it.
- We just have a one man
machine.
(men laugh)
- Yeah.
He's like, he works like 10 people's work.
He's just like, "I'll do it to myself."
- Yeah, damn, props to you.
- I do have solution
to that problem, you
know, if you're coming in
with like two and a half hours of footage
and you're having a hard
time cutting it down,
- Oh, yeah?
- have you ever thought about
this thing called a podcast?
(hosts laugh)
- Oh,
you mean just releasing it all like that?
- Yeah.
(hosts laugh)
- Have you ever thought about no cuts?
- I have thought about
that and people have asked,
they're like, "Come on,
just release the full thing.
I know you got it there somewhere."
But I feel like I'm too
much of a stickler for like,
I want it to really be polished.
I want everything that I come
out with to feel polished.
And I know there's an environment
where people want longer conversations
that are unedited.
- Mm, you're right.
- Like this one, obviously
has a huge audience,
even on YouTube where I feel like people
are not generally looking
for very long uncut things.
You guys found that audience,
and it clearly does exist.
- Right, yeah.
- But I just, I really
want something that feels
a little bit more bite size.
- But you could like take those parts
that you cut out, for example,
- Oh, yeah.
- turn it into like a compilation,
and release it on like Patreon
for like a behind the scenes or something.
- Oh, yeah, yeah,
- Have you thought
about doing that, or?
- for sure, for sure.
- Yeah, we definitely have a
bunch of archived conversations
that we are noting this
didn't really make the cut,
but it is still a strong conversation.
- I mean, with the amount of
questions I guess you're asking
and the amount of people you're asking,
I'm sure there's moments
there you're like,
"That question didn't go down great."
Or, "That was a little awkward.
Let's just cut that out, let's just-"
(men laugh)
- A little bit,
well, it depends, sometimes
the awkward questions
and answers have like-
- Are the best ones.
- Yeah, are the best ones
because it puts me on the spot
to come up with something
that was unplanned.
- Right.
- And I overthink
everything that I usually do
that it's the unplanned stuff
that actually gets outta my head
'cause I'm actually, you know,
- That makes sense.
Right, yeah.
- there in the moment.
But, yeah, sometimes I
just move right on, yeah.
- You're like, "All right, next question."
(hosts laugh)
- Yeah, yeah.
- That one didn't go too well.
- Sometimes we'll keep it in
of me being like, "Ah, so anyway, uh."
Of not knowing where to go with it.
Like when I interviewed dominatrixes
and some of the details that they said,
I don't think there was any response
that would've felt
appropriate in that moment
about some of the actions that
went down behind the scenes.
(hosts laugh)
Yeah, yeah.
I think I'm a little too
vanilla to have been prepared
for some of those responses.
- Is there a lot
you have to cut out to, let's say,
keep within YouTube guidelines?
- I mean, to a certain degree, yes.
Sometimes we just censor
it and that's enough
because we don't want the
video to be age gated,
and then it's like
- Ugh.
no one sees this video.
- Right.
- I mean, certain episodes, yeah,
I Spent a Day With Strippers,
I Spent a Day With Dominatrixes.
I mean, I'm gonna have
an upcoming episode,
I Spent a Day With Pony Players.
Look it up,
the actual word, maybe not.
- Oh.
- Maybe with a private browser.
Incognito window.
- I'm sorry,
what is a pony player?
- (laughs) So they are people that,
it's basically role play.
It's a little bit of dom and sub dynamic,
and they dress up as a pony,
kind of in a leather-
- I didn't know this.
- Like My Little Pony, or?
- Like, see-
(laughs) No, like-
(hosts laugh)
- Or just like an actual pony?
- Think about a human,
oh, here we go, we got some visuals
for you here.
- Oh.
- I've seen that before.
- Can you click on that
black and white one there?
I think that one's a pretty good dynamic.
Yeah, let's zoom in on that.
- That was on Twitter.
- Whoa.
- Let's take a look, so.
- Oh, wow!
- Oh!
- Yeah.
- Moving on, put these off.
- It's like a leather furry a little bit,
except it's BDSM, so it's not a furry
because those are not always associated
with anything sexually.
- Who's scouting
this stuff for you?
(hosts laugh)
- Yeah, yeah, so-
- Do you have a dude
(all chattering)
that's like, "Anthony, you won't
believe what I just found?"
- I mean, a little bit, yeah.
- Right.
- It's my producer Elise.
She's like, "So we got this
really interesting person.
She has an arena, you know,
where horses usually reside in,
but it's for the pony players.
Do you wanna add on a little segment
where you go on location?"
I was like, "Yeah, let's do it."
I didn't know how to react to that,
but the obvious answer is yes.
- Right, you have to do
it, it's the content.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You have to.
I mean, yeah, when I do a lot of episodes,
I Spent a Day With Dominatrixes,
I'm like, you have to dominate me.
(hosts laugh)
Like, that's part-
- I'm not into this, but you have to,
- You must dominate me.
- you have to
for journalistic integrity.
- So many comments are like,
"Clearly Anthony just wanted
to know what this was like."
Or like, "Clearly Anthony's a pro at this
'cause he didn't really have
that big of a reaction."
I was like, I mean, you know,
transparently, I wanted to
learn about dominatrixes
and the scene, I have to put myself in it
to really understand
the dynamic
- Of course.
- of why people would do this,
what do they take out of it,
what do they like about it?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, how do you battle
the inner embarrassment with it?
- You know, it's the weirdest
thing, when it's on camera,
it feels like it's for
research purposes literally.
(Garnt laughs)
To the point where,
and part of the humor and
entertainment comes from me
being embarrassed, which
makes me less embarrassed.
- Yeah.
- I get that.
- Does that make sense?
- I do videos in Japan,
a similar thing, I worked
in a strip club recently.
- Yeah, yeah, I did not
see that one specifically.
(men laugh)
But I saw one of 'em.
- You don't wanna,
you don't wanna.
- Are the strip clubs there different?
- Ah, yeah, a little bit, I guess.
I mean, I haven't been to any here.
- Oh, oh, shoot.
- Just tell me for research.
(men laugh)
- Research purposes.
- Can you take him
for research purposes?
- Yeah, you have to be able
to answer my question later.
You must go to a strip club tonight.
(men laughing)
- Yeah, I mean, I feel like, yeah,
when you're on camera, it kinda
gives you like a free pass
- Yes!
- to just be an embarrassment.
And not good.
(men laugh)
- I realized that the other
day, I went to this bar,
and there's this social anxiety
that's just like, uh-uh,
immediately like cut off any opportunity
to feel like outta my element.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- So I went to this thing and I was like,
"I'm just gonna push myself to do it."
And I was like, I was
thinking, I was like,
"I could totally do this
if cameras were on me."
And if it was like, I'm
like talking to the camera,
"I'm gonna be going to this thing,
I'm gonna be uncomfortable.
Let's see what happens."
And then I would be able to totally do it.
And I was trying to
reframe my mind to be like,
"Can I trick myself into
thinking there is a camera
following me and I'm doing
this for research purposes."
'Cause I would be a pro, I would be pro
at anything.
- There is an
invisible camera.
- Go to the toilet
and vlog, I mean.
- It's my invincibility.
I'm like, "I could do anything
if a camera is on me."
I don't know, it's weird.
- Tell me you're a YouTuber,
tell me you're a YouTuber.
- You're just
a content creator, like
through and through.
- It's true, it empowers you.
It feels like you have
a pass to just do it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- They're like,
"Oh, no, don't worry,
there's a camera on him."
"Oh, okay, okay."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like, if these cameras were not rolling
and we were all just sat down up there,
I feel like it might've
taken us an extra 10 minutes
to warm up, you know?
- Right.
- 'Cause it's weird, right?
There's like this invigoration
you can almost feel
from being on camera.
- Yeah, because normally,
like most of my content
is not on camera and the only
time I started going on camera
was like for this podcast.
And at first, I was like
really, really awkward.
And it was just really,
really weird being there.
But then you kinda get used to it
and it kinda becomes your friend.
- Right.
- It becomes like-
- It becomes a parasocial relationships,
dude, let's go.
- Yeah, yeah, it kinda becomes
like your excuse.
- The camera or the audience?
- Oh, no, the camera, the camera.
It becomes like the get out jail free card
for this shit you wouldn't
normally do, right?
- That's true, that's true
because part of the entertainment factor
comes from whatever happens.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, and-
- So you're forced
to lean into that.
- Yeah, and the people
around you as well, as soon
as they see you being filmed,
they're like, "Okay, they
can be a bit of a monkey
or whatever."
- You absolutely
get a free pass.
- I'll tell you what
is like the real free pass though.
So sometimes in Japan,
we bring the camera crew,
but for some reason, every time
we've brung like a boom mic,
- Oh, yeah?
- that is when people
around us know that shit's going down.
- Oh.
- Because, you know,
they see like a shotgun mic, right,
and they're like, "Oh, well, you know,
this is just a hobby
for someone, you know,
they're just filming for
their friends or whatever."
But when they see a massive
boom mic, they're like,
"Oh, this is real shit."
- Like, they're professional.
- They got a crew.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, "Excuse me, gentlemen,
do you want some coffee?"
"What do you need on set?"
"Thank you very much."
- They immediately think
we're like more important
than we actually are
the moment when they see the boom mic.
- Yeah, for sure.
- And we don't even use it,
mostly we just use a lapel mic.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
it's just for looks, man.
- It's just like a statement.
Yeah, yeah.
- Get out of jail free card.
But I was thinking back to, I was like,
there have definitely been
moments of things that I've shot
that I would be so embarrassed
if the cameras weren't rolling.
And I did this video, I Spent
a Day With Anime Cafe Maids,
- I saw that one.
- I saw that one, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, okay, okay.
And I said if this video
gets over 100,000 likes,
I will become a maid and
I will make a documentary
about me doing a show.
And I actually put it on,
put the show on with the
girls that I had interviewed.
And I look back at that
and I had the most
confidence in the world,
like zero bit of embarrassment
about literally stepping on people
and having my full on ass cheeks out.
But I was like, if the
cameras were not rolling,
I would've been like, "I
don't want this attention."
It was something about
knowing the cameras are there
and I'm trying to, you know,
almost like I'm working,
like, "I'm fucking working here, guys."
Like something about that, I
was just like, "It's okay."
- It's like a little devil
that's sitting on your shoulder
being like, "Don't
worry, it's for content."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(men laugh)
I don't know if that's a good thing.
- Just like a professional
through and through, you know,
it's like, you know, when you're an actor
and the director says, you know, fucking,
what do they say again?
- Action.
- Fucking, action.
(men laughing)
I was like, I just went-
- You're in LA, Garnt,
you need to know this.
- I'm sorry, okay, I'm sorry,
it's only been five days in LA, okay?
- I feel like when I go
into a lot of the videos,
I'm like, "I will never get
a chance to do this again."
Like you can't make a-
- Oh, true.
- It's true.
- You could do the video
again, but you can't really.
- No, no, no, it'll never
be the same reactions.
- No one's gonna click
it again, or they will,
but, you know, it's not the same.
- It's not the same, yeah.
- I was having a conversation
with someone recently
and I was trying to figure out
why I feel like I'm in
such a different head space
when I'm conducting an interview.
I mean, part of it is
that I've done a pre-call,
part of it is that I know where
the conversation's gonna go
to a certain degree,
but also in many ways,
I feel like it might be, it's
like the last conversation
I'll ever have with this person.
Not to say that I'll never
talk to them or whatever again,
but for some reason there is,
like, this is this one moment.
In a way it feels like there's all
this pressure.
- It's like make it count.
- Yeah.
And even though there's a lotta pressure,
for some reason the fact
that it feels so dire,
it almost alleviates the
pressure in a weird way.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Knowing that you can kind
of go for the deep questions
and really push forward.
- Yeah, yeah, like this is
your one shot, kinda like
what you were saying.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
- That's awesome.
- When you started,
did you ever feel like, I guess,
nervous being too intrusive
or, you know, kind of like
- Oh.
- diving down a bit too deep?
- Yeah, a little bit.
I mean, I would tell people beforehand,
like if there's any question
that you don't wanna answer,
don't ever feel like I'm trying to pry
further than you're comfortable.
Then I would tell them, tell
me to not if I'm going down
in a direction that you're
not comfortable with,
but now that I do the pre-calls,
again, that removes most of that.
Sometimes I'll drill down
a little bit further.
But for the most part, I
see if they're comfortable
and I try to word the questions in a way
where they can tell me
as much as they want
or go in as much as they want.
Sometimes they'll tell me something,
if I wanna get in deeper,
I'll be like, "Oh,"
and I'll kind of rephrase
what they just said to me.
Which sounds really stupid,
if we just leave it in,
it's me saying the exact
same thing that they said.
But for some reason hearing it back,
I feel like they know that I understood.
And then it gives them
the opportunity to refine
or dig in deeper if they want.
So usually it's like, I kind
of throw out little invitations
to go deeper without
feeling like I'm prying in.
- Okay.
- Right, right.
- So it's like their choice
if they would like to go
down if they want to.
- Yeah, yes.
Yes, exactly.
- Right, yeah,
that's pretty smart to do.
- Yeah.
- It sounded like you're
describing a different experience.
(men laugh)
Consent. (laughs)
- I didn't mean for it
to come out like that.
- You know he just took
what he said and explained it sexually?
So it's their choice
(men laugh)
to go down.
- It's their choice
- So you're telling me
it's their choice?
(men laughing)
- They don't have to.
- So, obviously, it's like
a massive interview series
on YouTube now, but you came off of this
like off the back of "Smosh."
What made you want to
start doing this series?
Was it, did you want to
explore a bunch of ideas
and then this was the one
that like kinda stuck,
or was it always this
that you wanted to do?
- Well, I mean, you know,
"Smosh" was definitely a comedic,
like silly thing, so I never thought
that I was gonna get into
any deeper conversations,
like connecting with people
in the way that the series is now.
And the whole series kinda
started off as a joke,
of course, the very
first video when I left,
I was like, okay, part of the joke
was that I'm an independent YouTuber now,
I have no idea what's,
I mean, it was-
- I'm a strong,
independent YouTuber.
- I was feeling myself.
And it was actually very true,
I had not uploaded my own video in years
because the company had taken it over.
So part of the joke was like, hey,
what does an independent YouTuber do now?
And I was asking for advice
and I interviewed a bunch
of popular YouTubers.
And there was something about that dynamic
of having a conversation
where I didn't know
where it was going.
And the funniest moments were
the ones that were improvised
rather than 100% scripted.
And I really enjoyed that.
And then later on it
was like, let's revisit.
And I was struggling for a
long time, just floundering,
like what do I do with this channel?
And every single week it was like,
I don't know what to do.
Okay, I figured it out.
Okay, I shot it. Okay, I hate it.
So now I'm gonna figure
something else out.
Okay, I find the shot, now
I'm releasing this thing
that I don't really like,
but I ran outta time.
And eventually I was
like, what were the things
that I liked doing most
on the channel so far?
Let's, you know, I'll dial
in deeper with those ideas.
And then I started
expanding on it from there.
- Yeah.
- Man, Japan needs to start listening
to how you do your interviews.
'Cause you would hate how
interviews are done in Japan.
- I don't think I've ever
heard a Japanese interview.
Tell me about it.
- Oh, bro,
It's miserable.
- Oh, God, so-
- Do you guys get
interviewed like on Japanese-
- No, so when you do
interviews with anyone,
you have to give them the exact script
of the interview.
- Oh!
- And there's no room
for error.
- Yeah, and they will
sometimes have scripted answers
about what they will say to you back.
So everything is pre-planned.
You are not allowed to
go off-script at all.
And it's just the most rigid interview
you could like ever imagine.
- Is it like that in different
places of Asia as well?
Because
- I don't know.
- Maybe.
- I've also interviewed
someone from South Korea,
and it was a similar thing
where, well, they were
speaking English to me,
and it was obviously not
their first language.
So it was like, of
course, they want to know
what they're saying.
- That makes sense, yeah.
- They wanted the questions
beforehand and I figured,
yeah, they wanna know
what I'm saying to them
just in case a word slips
by that they don't know.
But I didn't realize what
they were doing was scripting
their responses to such
a degree that afterwards
they sent me their script.
- Yeah.
- Oh, geez.
- Oh, wow.
- And
I thought it was a little
bit weird in the moment,
whenever I'd ask a question,
they would repeat the answer
that they had already said.
And I was like, "Hmm, okay,
well, they were a lot more loose
in the pre-interview just talking to me
about all these things."
And then here I was like,
"Maybe they're just nervous or something.
Okay, I get it, people get nervous."
But then they sent me a
script and it was verbatim,
every single word that was said.
- Wow.
- So I think
they had a teleprompter.
- Yeah, I think like,
'cause I have done quite
a bit of interviews
with industry people in Japan
and a lot of them are like,
"Okay, send me a list
of questions beforehand.
We will approve all the questions.
We will write up like
a very basic thing. "
And I'm like, "Okay, that's fine."
But I've done enough
now where I'm just like,
"Okay, we'll follow you're script,
but I'm gonna add extra questions."
- Yeah, yeah.
(Garnt laughs)
- "And you won't be prepared for them.
And so I can really catch you out
on what you actually feel."
And for the most part,
they're okay with it
when it actually happens.
But I think if you tell them
beforehand, "Hey, by the way,
I'm gonna throw in some extra questions,"
they'll just freak out.
'Cause they'll be like, we're not prepared
for that.
- Their teams will say,
"We can't do that."
- Yeah, their teams
will be like, "No, you can't do that."
But when I do it on the
day of the recording
and I get a good answer and a
good conversation flow going,
then they're like, "Oh, maybe it's okay.
Maybe it actually makes for
an interesting interview."
(men laugh)
- They're not out
to fuck me over.
- Yeah, exactly.
Maybe they actually are just
like genuinely interested
in me and want a good interview.
- I wonder how many people
have to be screwed over,
like in order for that to become
the standard, right?
- Yeah, it's like, how many
bad interviews must have you have done
for you to get to that point?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- But it does take a
while to kinda build up
- Rapport.
- that rapport
and that level of respect or trust
with people, you know?
- Yeah, definitely.
And I've seen that, too.
I have people that are
a lot more comfortable
with doing my interviews now
than I think that they
probably would've been
a couple years ago before
I had really, you know,
I don't know if I wanna
call it proven myself,
but I guess proven that
I'm not going to purposely
and maliciously try to like defame someone
and ruin their career.
- Right, right.
- You never really showcase
even like, you know,
what most people consider strange things,
you never really show it as like, "Whoa,
look at this weird thing."
You're just like, "These are real people.
Let's just see why real
people do what they do."
- Yeah, and if it is a strange thing,
I like to talk with them about
how it's a strange thing.
You know?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
- And the thing is,
most people are absolutely willing to talk
about how something
that they do is strange.
It's not like they are so
like in a different world
that they think everyone should do this.
And if they think it's
weird, then fuck you,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But you've had people like that though,
right, in the past?
- In which way?
- In the sense of them
trying to prove a point
and being like, "No, you're weird
for thinking that this
is weird," kinda thing?
- A little bit, but it still
seems a little playful.
They're like, "Normies don't get this."
You know what I mean?
(hosts laugh)
So they still, I think, recognize that.
But definitely people are
a little bit defensive,
but I think it's because
they've been shown enough times
that they feel like they
have to be defensive,
'cause that means that
someone doesn't respect them.
And I think it's just a lot of like vying
for respect of people.
- Do you ever find people
that it's a different field
where you're just talking
to someone casually,
but when you're in an
interview setting with cameras,
you really have to make
them feel comfortable
like being themselves and talking,
did you find that a challenge
with your interviews at all?
Just getting people to
be comfortable on camera
as quick as possible?
- A little, I mean, yeah.
And you bring up a good point.
I do obviously have a limited time
and I can't just spend the first like hour
of the interview warming up.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So I go outta my way
to really connect with people.
You know, we have the pre-interview call,
so there's a little bit of that dynamic
where we're already laughing together
and we already are on the same page.
So there's that when they show up.
But, of course, they're
a little bit more tense,
but I'll meet the guests on the street,
I'll walk them in, I'll
bring them out to the back.
We do our COVID tests and
we hang out, you know,
like on this park bench
that I have on my balcony,
and we just chit chat,
and I get to know them.
And I tell them a lot about myself.
So I think that there's like a method
to kinda warming people
up so that they can see
that you're genuine and
that you're not secretly
gonna be trying to get a one up on them.
- We shoulda done that.
(men laugh)
- I should take him out back.
(all chattering)
- Dad, Anthony just turned up
and we were like, "All
right, camera's on."
- Yeah, right, let's
go, come on, chop-chop.
- Now, we used to do something similar.
We called it like, I don't know,
I don't know if it was a
strat, but the Denny strat.
So there was a Denny's
outside of our office
and often I'd invite
them to lunch beforehand
to like get to know them,
have a casual conversation.
But one issue we always
found ourselves having
was we'd get into a conversation
and it would just be like,
"Shit, this is good material.
This is good."
I mean, it literally happened
like the five minutes
since after we sat down
and we're like, "Shit,
let's just not ask any questions.
Because this is like good material
that we can go through now.
- And that's part of the challenge also.
I mean, (laughs) the
closer you get to someone,
the more you start connecting with them,
the more you start talking about things
that are then difficult to bring back up
and have it feel like the
first time you talked about it.
But that's what helps having
my questions all ready
because we actually go away
from those conversations
for a little while.
And then if we have a good conversation,
you know, I'll write it down in my notes.
And I'll be like, "This is a good,
we need to bring this back up again."
- That's a good idea.
- Right, smart,
we should take notes.
- We should definitely
take notes.
(men laughing)
- This isn't a podcast,
we're literally just
asking for advice now.
- It's like, how do you do it?
(men laugh)
- You guys didn't have to,
I coulda just sent you a message.
(hosts laugh)
- It's like, where were
the questions, bro?
- Yeah, no, this is great.
- So we were talking about before,
like how many people you
have to run this show now.
So how many people are
there behind the scenes
and how many did you start off with?
- Yes, so I started off with
just two camera operators
and it was just myself
trying to figure out
what the fuck I was doing.
And then I slowly but surely
had new people come on
to help me and now I have 10 employees
on the show.
- Wow, Jesus.
- And, you know,
- Is it that nice?
- it doesn't sound like
that big of a number
until you think about how much
everyone needs to be paid.
(men laughing)
- That's the law,
that's the law.
- Yeah, that's the law,
- And there's a lot of moving parts.
So, you know,
when I started, I took two
years of community college
and I started to take business
administration classes.
"Smosh" started happening 2005
and I was like, "Ah, fuck college."
But I realized I have actually
always been interested
in managing a team and a business.
And I think it's a lot of
fun, you know, teaching.
And especially once you could teach,
like I have a head of post, a main editor,
and I get to teach him all the things
and we get on the same page.
And then there's four
people that work, I guess
below him is how people would say it,
but that work with him.
And so I get to communicate
with one person,
he communicates with four.
So I just really enjoy the dynamic
of a whole team working together
and having it feel like
a well-oiled machine.
- 'Cause I was gonna ask, how many people
did you have at most when you
were at "Smosh," like working?
- Oh my God, well-
- How many employees
did you have then?
- It's kinda hard to say
because Defy owned "Smosh."
And they I think had 30 people working
- Geez.
- with "Smosh"
and all the side channels and
the live events and the live,
yeah, there's so many
elements there that I guess 30
was the magic number.
I don't even think I
met some of the people
that were working there.
(hosts laugh)
- They're there somewhere.
- It was a weird team situation
where we all never really
got to know each other fully.
- Obviously, you know, we're YouTubers,
you see that lovely one out of 10 system,
which is the most
depressing system on earth.
And it's very black-
- Or it's the best system
in the world, one outta 10.
- Our viewers have heard
us complain about it
like a million times.
But I imagine when you have 10 employees
that suddenly if you're
getting a 10 outta 10
and then maybe you get a nine outta 10,
it starts to get a lot scarier, right,
when you got more people?
- Yeah, there's a lot
more weight.
- Yeah.
I mean, how do you deal with that?
Do you deal with it as
a team or are you like,
"Guys, leave me alone,
I'm gonna cry a moment?"
(men laugh)
- There's still a part of
me that is affected by it.
I can't say that there's not.
And it's not even like
an outward thing of like,
"Ah, shit, dude, what am I gonna do?"
But even if I just carry on with my day,
there is a part of me where like my energy
feels a little bit like
something was pulled out
- No, definitely, definitely.
- from me a little bit.
- Of course, right.
- Even if I'm not thinking about it,
it must be some suppressed shit.
(hosts laugh)
And then when there is
like a one outta 10,
I'm ooh, my posture's a little better,
(hosts laugh)
But I've been really
working on reminding myself
that a bad video now was
actually a good video for me,
like in terms of performance.
- That's true.
- When I first started, you
know, what I would now consider
like probably a lower performing video
was a good performing video
and we still have sponsors.
And I still, I try to look
at what my actual progress
has been for the show,
it's not just views.
That is, it's so easy to think views
are a measure of progress
because it's the biggest number.
When you go on YouTube,
it's attached to every single thumbnail.
In fact, many people decide
if they're gonna click
on something based on
how high that number is.
You see one video and it
has, you know, 10,000 views,
someone is much less likely
than to click that same video
with 10 million views because
there's that curiosity aspect
of wait, why,
- Why was this watched?
- so many people are watching this,
there's gotta be something
brilliant in there, right?
- If there is a YouTube
video under 30 seconds
that has over a million views,
you know it's a banger.
- Yes, you know you're gonna
click it.
- You know it's always
a fucking banger.
- And that shit's
gonna be delivered to you
so quickly, 30 seconds,
that's it,
(hosts laugh)
30 seconds to have a banger.
- Instant serotonin.
- I'm fine with that.
But that is not my only measure
of where I'm going with this.
A part of it is also like,
I wanna grow respect and have people trust
that I will treat them
with respect on the show.
So I'm having people with huge names,
people have started to reach
out to me and say like,
"Ooh, I'd love to be
on the show sometime."
And that's something
that I never had before.
So regardless of where my numbers go,
I have people that I really
respect reaching out to me
and wanting to talk with me
and like have that experience
of being on the show.
And that is something that is so cool.
And I could clearly see kind of
that's my metric path now.
- That's the path
that you were on,
the greater community.
- Yeah, exactly, yeah.
- I mean, so the whole YouTube system
and giving a shit about analytics,
was that something that,
I suppose, that "Smosh"
under Defy Media that you
never concerned yourself with?
- I didn't really because
we were just on a salary.
- Right, right, right.
- So I was like,
these numbers don't affect me.
- Yeah, I definitely came
in there like, Anthony, man,
it's not doing too hard
'cause you're on a salary.
- Yeah, I'm like, oh, man,
well, it looks like I
have two more years, so.
(men laugh)
- Geez.
- So it must have been like
you were under "Smosh,"
then under Defy Media,
and then now you're separate.
So there's probably that big gap
where you didn't really take notice
of what was really
happening on YouTube much.
Wow, that's interesting.
- So now I had to start learning
all these things.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- When did you kind of tune
out of like giving a fuck
about what was happening on YouTube
or like kind of not
paying as much attention
and just doing it
every time you get to work?
- Ah, you mean like
when I was Defy?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'd say it was probably
around 2014 or 2015
probably, to 2017 when I eventually left
and decided to do my own thing.
I think it was the two
years that I was unhappy
with where things were going,
and the way that the
company was being ran,
and the decisions that were being made.
And how I was being left in the dark
about a lotta decisions
that were really important
that were being made.
And it was around then that I started
to just kinda tune out from
YouTube in general, you know,
I would still put a lot of my
heart into making the things
that I was making at that time,
but there was still this part of me
that was just getting detached from it.
And that's when I kinda stopped caring
about browsing YouTube
and being part of the community as much.
- Just when you thought you were out,
you got dragged right in.
(men laugh)
- Yeah,
I almost made it out the rat race.
- So do you think not caring
about it gave you more
or less freedom than you do now?
Because now you do have to
care about the algorithm.
Every YouTuber has to
care about the algorithm,
unfortunately.
- Yeah.
- I think it's kind of about
caring about the right things.
And by the right things, you know,
it's not to say there's a
wrong thing to care about,
but like the figuring out
what is meaningful for you
and then caring about those things.
- Right, right.
- It's so easy to start caring
about the things that seem
like they matter most,
like, you know, just
straight up view count.
But then you could drill in,
you could read the comments
and see how much of an
impact a certain thing made.
And you know, you could realize
that that is more important.
So you have to define the
things that matter most to you
before you just start
caring about everything.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Damn.
- So like you mentioned
something earlier just off the cuff,
but you were just like, yeah,
so I quit college in 2005
because "Smosh" was a thing.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- What?
- Yeah.
- So you quit college
in 2005 to do YouTube?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Wow, that's super,
that's super letting it go.
- Well, okay, okay,
can I just say something?
- Yeah, that was really,
really good.
(men laughing)
- They were like solid.
- Yeah.
- Mom, I made one Pokemon
Dollar, I'm going,
I'm quitting.
- Basically.
(men laughing)
I said it a little wrong.
So I went to two full semesters,
so I think it was technically 2006.
And I was signing up for classes
and I was thinking about
the amount of time,
'cause the classes obviously get harder
the further along you
get with your degree.
'Cause they start dialing into
the actual difficult things.
And I was like, okay, I could be doing
all these extremely
difficult things for this,
or, you know, which was now taking my time
away from this other thing
that is now starting to build,
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity.
I felt like I was almost
the master of my own fate
with this world, while I felt
like getting a college degree,
while obviously super
helpful for most people,
I felt like this is something
I can always come back to.
- Right.
- And also, this kinda
puts me in a position where
I'm following a system
that other people have
put in place for me,
I felt like I was making
up my own rules on YouTube.
- So did you like foresee
the fucking ecosystem
YouTube would become or you're just like?
(hosts laugh)
- No, no.
I'm like, ah, I see it all.
- Well, you were confident
enough to be like,
"Bye, collage," you know?
- No.
- Did you just have this,
like 'cause obviously,
how many videos or where
were you at at that point
when you decided to quit college?
What kinda stage was it at?
- I think we had, (laughs)
(men laugh)
- How many?
- I think we had six videos out.
(hosts laugh)
- What the fuck?
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
- Would you ever recommend
to a YouTuber with six videos-
- No,
never do what I did.
(hosts laugh)
Never do what I do unless
your parents are very well off
and they're totally fine
with you not doing college.
And they wanna help you.
- How many subs did you have
when you quit?
- (sighs) The subs
were not a thing.
(Garnt laughs)
- Oh, they weren't a thing?
- Wait, they weren't a thing?
- They were called followers
and
- Wow.
(men laugh)
- they were not a thing.
But the reason that I felt confident
is because this outside
company that was competing
with YouTube called (beep),
it does not exist anymore,
they reached out to us and they were like,
they gave us this contract
that was in hindsight very shitty.
But we were college kids
who were still living
under our parents' roofs.
And we were like, you know
what? This makes sense.
We can fund these things
that we love doing.
Like we just had the best time hanging out
and just laughing our
asses off, creating things.
And like, that's what the college kids
really wanna do most of the time.
Not the homework.
- Man, you get one paycheck
and you're like, "I am set for life.
Mother, I have a career now."
(men laugh)
- So we signed a two-year contract
with this outside company.
They offered us 3,600
bucks to split between us.
- For two years?
- For two year, each,
no, no each month.
- Oh, okay, okay, okay.
- I was like.
(Garnt laughs)
- I know, I know, I know.
It sounded worse, but it's
still not great though.
So we each got 1,800 bucks
and we each also invested
our own money from that
into the videos themselves.
And they also give us a
little bonus at the beginning.
So I had this piece of shit car
and like I couldn't do anything
'cause every time I got in my car,
it would not work, anyway.
So I bought a new car and
I was like, you know what?
This, like, we have a
two-year contract here,
we're pretty safe, I could
come back to do these classes
if I really I need to.
- That makes way more sense.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I just did six videos, yeah.
- It was like one of the
first deals where a company
was like trying to compete with YouTube
and take their audience away.
And part of their contract was this video
has to be exclusive to us for two weeks.
And after the two week period,
you can release it to YouTube,
but it has to have a brought
to you (beep) tag on the front
and at the end, and a watermark on it.
- Oh, shit.
- So we like-
- It's kind of generous that
they even let you do that.
- It was, but their whole
strategy for marketing
was that they were trying
to steal the audience
from YouTube.
- Right.
- So the only way for
them to get an audience
on their platform was to let people know.
But, unfortunately, they
didn't have anything to offer
that was bigger than the scope
of what YouTube had to offer.
I don't need to get into
the legality behind it,
but eventually we were able
to get out of that contract
because they promised us a certain,
wow, I don't know if I shoulda
said that company name.
(men laugh)
- You wanna bleep it out?
- Do you wanna bleep it?
- We can bleep it out.
- All right, Mudan,
bleep it out, okay, yes.
- Okay, thank you.
Bleep out the company name. (laughs)
- And now you can go ahead.
- So now I feel
more comfortable.
(men laugh)
Now I feel comfortable saying everything.
So they promised a certain
amount of marketing value
and they translated that to
a certain amount of views.
It was like some odd millions of views
they were promising to bring to our videos
on our channel on their platform.
They did not live up to that.
And when we started
getting on them about that,
we found out, I'm wondering
how much I should say, (laughs)
this is how many years ago now?
Jesus, it's 16 years ago.
- Jesus.
- Maybe it's okay, I
think that everyone there
is probably in a diff, I don't
know, buried underground.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- So
what I realized they
started doing to fulfill
their end of the bargai,
- Oh no.
- Right.
- was, well, first I noticed that, oh,
we had a million new views on our video
on this channel this day.
- Oh.
- Okay, so this website where our videos
usually get 5,000 views
are now getting 1,005,000 views,
there's something up here.
(hosts laugh)
- So-
- Oh.
- So I go into the comments
and I get,
"Fuck "Smosh,"
What is this bullshit?
I'm trying to look at
my MP3s, and this is."
"Why is this playing?"
I find out that they also
own this other website
and they have a little hidden eye frame
that's like autoplaying our videos
in the background
- No!
- of this other website.
- Oh, shit. What the fuck?
- No way!
No way.
- So they'd go to this website
and then they'd hear
the audio of our videos
while they're trying to fucking
browse this other website.
And it would count as a view.
(Garnt laughs)
- Oh my God.
- So eventually we were able
to get outta the contract
'cause we were like,
this is not very cool.
It's actually giving us a bad reputation
'cause people think
that we are doing this.
And then eventually we were
able to get outta that.
And it was at that time
that both, oh my God,
Myspace was trying to launch
(hosts laugh)
a video platform.
- I'm not sure if kids today
know what a Myspace is.
- No, no, it's your space.
- Yeah.
(hosts laugh)
- So they were trying to
launch a video platform
and they came to us with an offer,
- Oh my God.
- and then YouTube was like,
"Hey, there's this program
where you can make money
on your videos on our platform
that never had any ads before,
would you like to be one
of the first 10 channels
to ever make
- No fucking way.
- any money on here?"
- Geez.
- "We'll give you a guarantee."
And even though their guarantee
was lower than Myspace,
thank everything in the world we said,
"Yeah, we'll stick with YouTube."
And that's kinda where everything started.
That was early 2007.
That's when we-
- Geez.
- Was that just like,
were you guys just guessing or
did you genuinely feel like,
I think YouTube's gonna be the king?
- There was this feeling,
also we had a video on there,
our Pokemon Theme Song Lip Sync video.
(men laugh)
- I saw it,
classic, classic,
- Banger,
banger of a video.
- classic video.
- It's like "The Godfather,"
you know, you go on the IMDb
page of like YouTube videos
and that's like at the top.
- Top 100 YouTube videos.
It's up there.
- It would be,
if there was a IMDb
- It would be.
- for YouTube.
- In our brains,
in our brains.
- In our brains, yeah.
In our brains.
- So that video, I
think, had something like
25 million views.
- Jesus Christ.
- God.
- And it was easy
to see that the market, the
viewership was on YouTube
and they had just been
purchased by Google for,
you know, way too cheap. (laughs)
Which is still billions of dollars.
And I felt really good about Google.
I felt good about where they're going.
Even though I met Tom from Myspace myself,
I was like, "Mm, Google."
- But you met the creator
of Myspace?
- Yeah, yeah, briefly.
- What was he like?
- He was just a dude.
I mean, I don't know, a
dude wearing a nice jacket.
I don't know.
- Did he do this thing?
(men laugh)
- He did not, I feel like
everything within him was like,
I can't do that, I can't even
give a thumbs up or a smile.
No, no, he was a good guy.
I think he does-
- Did he add you on Myspace?
- Was he, were you in-
- I don't know,
we were already friends, bro.
(hosts laugh)
- Yeah, but was he in
your top eight friends?
That's the real question.
- He became part of my
top eight after I thought
I might have a deal with him.
- Ah, shit.
(men laugh)
- My top eight
business friends.
- I'm like, shit,
if he goes on my page, he's gonna know,
(hosts laugh)
ah, shit.
I think he's in photography now
and he is a good photographer.
But anyway, so I went with YouTube,
we went with YouTube, Ian
and I made the decision
to go with YouTube there.
And obviously it was the right choice.
It just felt right, you know?
- Yeah, absolutely.
- So you were getting paid
even before there was even
like an economy on YouTube
or anything like that.
- Yeah, yeah, (laughs)
the funny part is that all they
were was the lower third ad,
the little tiny thing that
pops up at like 15, 20 seconds.
And even then, you know,
we were afraid of the
backlash that we might get
for that.
- That's so funny.
- So,
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- we enabled it on our older videos.
And then the newest video we'd wait
'til like our bigger
audience came in and left,
so that we wouldn't get flack for it.
- No way.
- And even on
our older videos, people were like,
"Whoa, you fucking sellout."
(men laugh)
There's an ad where you go, your mouse.
No one's on mobile,
you're on your computer.
And all you have to do is move
your mouse and click the X.
And people are like, "Ugh, fuck this!"
- There's one extra step I have to do!
- Now people watch videos and
there's a minute and a half
of unskippable ads six times in a video.
- And whenever YouTube gets
sponsored, they're like,
"Yes, King, make that money."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, but no.
- Did you get backlash when
you had your first sponsor?
'Cause I feel like
YouTube ads are one thing.
- Every YouTuber did I think.
- Oh, oh you mean Smoothie King?
- Was that one-
- Was that your first sponsor?
- (laughs) That was our first sponsor,
it's called Smoothie King.
It was this like, I don't
know if they're independent
or if they're like a chain,
but they're a smoothie place
in like Austin, Texas,
or I forget.
- Fuck off.
- Somewhere in Texas.
- No way.
- I don't know.
- Are you serious?
- And, yeah, we just had to
make a little video there
and put it out, we didn't even
put it on our main channel,
our second channel.
They paid us like a couple
thousand or something.
And it was like, you know,
that was our first sponsor.
- What was the reception
to that though?
- What the fuck is this?
(hosts laugh)
But-
- Oh, YouTube seems so wild.
Some weird shit.
- There were absolutely
no rules, and I remember
when I first started,
I would actually go outta
my way to break rules
to show YouTube that this
rule could be broken.
I'm just a bad boy.
(hosts laugh)
- Like what, like what?
- And one thing that
I realized is that there
was this channel that,
I can't remember what the name of it was,
in fact it's probably better
that I don't say the name,
they had videos that would just pop off.
But they'd have like 12
comments and I was like,
this math doesn't add up.
And of course, as an 18-year-old kid,
I was like, "I must get
down to the bottom of this.
It's my duty."
- Internet detective mode.
- Yeah, yeah.
So I did a test on our Myspace
and it was kind of what I
learned from that other company
doing the hidden eye frame thing.
So I realized on Myspace,
- Oh.
- you can hide an eye frame as well.
Which is ridiculous, I think,
that anyone could have any
page load in the background.
So I hid it on our page and
I realized that that worked.
So I said, "YouTube, fix this."
I don't know. I don't know
if it was even me saying it.
But also a big thing was that that channel
was also having hundreds of
thousands of new subscribers,
I think it was right when
they announced subscribing.
And I was like, how is this channel
that gets so little comments
having so many views and subscribers?
So I also hid an eye frame on our channel.
or on our Myspace,
that auto subscribed
people to our channel.
And after like a day, I was
like, "Ye, yeah, this is gross.
I'm not gonna have this on here."
So I removed it, we got like
100, 200 new subscribers,
I felt gross about it.
And I think in order
to repent for my sins,
I went to YouTube and I was like,
"This is a way that people
are cheating the system."
So then YouTube, like
within the next couple days,
added a, on the subscribe
page they had a little button
that said are you sure
you wanna subscribe?
- Was that back when you
could actually talk to YouTube
and get through to them?
- Yes, yes.
Especially if you had a
big audience on YouTube,
you had, it was like concierge service.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- You just kinda get shit done?
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Wow.
- Yeah, we went and hung
out in, I don't know,
I don't remember, San, I don't
know, San Bruno, San Jose,
some San, near San Francisco.
- What was that?
- And, you know, hung out with
people there that work there.
- Wow.
- I met Chad Hurley,
Steve Chen,
the creators on YouTube.
- No way.
- Damn, dude.
- We just don't
have enough subscribers.
(men laugh)
We need to fix that.
- Think of the good old days,
right?
- Yeah.
- It was so rare, though, for
people to have an audience
because most people that uploaded videos
to YouTube
- One off viral clips
and stuff like that.
- were one off viral clips.
So it was very rare for
people to have audiences
and have recurring, you know,
videos of a specific channel.
So I think that they really
treated everyone back then
as like their gems that
were keeping the channel,
or like making YouTube
be something bigger.
- 'Cause I remember back in
the day, it was just like,
you would go on the most viewed,
you'd go on like the
most viewed of all time,
and obviously the Pokemon
Lip Sync was there.
You have like "Evolution of Dance,"
- Dude, ah!
- fucking
Charlie Bit My Finger.
- Classics.
Classics.
- You know, the classics,
you know, the classics.
- Yeah, because I always
forget, at one point, you were
the most subscribed channel
on the platform.
- Yeah, yeah,
two separate times.
- Two separate times, yeah.
- There was like a three month period
and a eight month period
or something, I forget.
- How was that?
Like, how was it, at one
point, you were at the top?
- It was really cool.
- Was there pressure, though? I bet.
- There was definitely pressure.
And it filtered the way
that I looked at everything
that I did for better or worse.
There was the good of like,
"Ooh, everything that I
make has some kind of value.
I should put a lot of my
time and energy in this
'cause I know a lotta
people are gonna see it."
And it really pushed me to
constantly be pushing myself
outside my boundary, or
outta my comfort zone
because I knew that it would, you know,
not literally pay off,
but it would pay off in the
sense that a lotta people
would see it and potentially
be able to enjoy it.
But then on the opposite side of that,
there was a lot of getting in
my own head about the pressure
and how I have to live up to this.
And then you're also always
seeing comments of people
saying like, how is this, whatever.
And it's a lot of filtering
it out to be like,
it doesn't matter that some
people don't like this,
it's not for them.
But it would get in my head of like,
"Oh, I need to be better."
And it was a lot of like this pressure.
- You were mentioning
earlier about how, obviously,
when you started, you got
a deal from a company.
I imagine when it was starting to ramp up
and get to like number
one most subscribed,
you're probably getting
offered all sorts of weird
and predatory stuff, and
probably just the most stressful
company meetings ever.
- Yeah.
- Dude, we had someone
show up to my house,
I was living with my mom, obviously,
in just like our small little tiny house
outside of Sacramento, California.
And there was this predator,
I don't wanna call him predatory,
but this guy came up in a business suit,
and he's like,
- Oh God.
- knocked on the door.
My mom was like, "There's someone outside
to see you."
- Oh no.
- So Ian and I walk out and
we're like, "What is up?"
And he's like, "Oh, I got your address
because I saw that you just
registered for a business
and it was marked under this address.
So I figured I would just show
up and tell you a few things
about like what you could be doing,
- What the fuck?
- how you could be
monetizing this."
And I was like,
I mean, I was 18
- What the fuck?
- so I didn't know.
- That's fucked up.
- And it was my first time
with like any kind of fame or labeling.
I didn't know that this was
a fucked up thing to do.
So I entertained it.
- Come on inside.
- (laughs) Yeah, come in,
would you like some tea?
- Okay, I drew the line there.
I did not invite him inside.
(hosts laugh)
There was no invitations inside.
But luckily, he was a vampire
and he could not enter
without me inviting him in.
(hosts laugh)
No, so he was like, "Okay, so,
your Pokemon Theme Song music video."
(men laugh)
Like it's this epic
piece of cinematic work.
And he was like, "It has 3 million views.
So think about it this way,
I could get you sponsored by Coca-Cola."
- Oh my God.
(Garnt laughs)
- And if you get $1,000 per million,
it gets $3,000 in your
pocket (clicks) like that."
And I was like, "First of
all, do you actually know,
do you have any contacts with Coca-Cola?"
(hosts laugh)
And he just started listing
all, and I realized immediately
that he was full of shit.
- He was full of shit.
- He was trying to make
some kind of a connection.
And he was like, "But
like then McDonald's."
And I was like, "Dude."
So he clearly didn't know
what he was talking about.
Luckily, he only showed up
one other time after that.
- One other time.
- Only one other time.
- One other time!
- One other time.
I was like, "Mom, when
that guy shows up again,
you just ignore that man.
(hosts laugh)
The bad man in the suit,
leave him."
- Oh my God.
- But luckily, we were, I
mean, we were not very smart,
but we were smart enough to know that
that did not feel right.
- Right, yeah, dude.
- 'Cause we were talking
to like Sean Jacksepticeye
like a few weeks ago,
and how back in like the
early days of YouTube,
there was just no boundaries between fans
and like the creator.
So fans would literally
show up at his house.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Did that happen
to you a lot?
- Oh, absolutely.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, yeah.
So Ian and I ended up
renting this place together,
he and I, and we had another
roommate with us too.
And we lived there for,
I think, four years.
And that's when our videos
were really, really,
really starting to become
popular, like 2009 to 2011-ish.
And so many ridiculous stories
of like mobs of people,
- What?
- like, I'm trying to edit
in my editing room and I
just hear people running
around the house and laughing
and looking through our trash.
- What the fuck?
- What? What?
- People did not know boundaries
and it was difficult.
- How did they find out
where you live?
- Because we were really stupid.
(hosts laugh)
And so all blame is on us.
But we would just shoot
outside of our house.
- I was about to say, yeah.
- Our address would be in it,
our cross street,
- Oh, no.
- cross streets of like, they
knew exactly how to find us.
And we-
- Because this was also
during the time where you
were doing the Mail Unboxings
on the same channel, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I bet that also came
into it as well, right?
- Yeah.
- I remember like,
you know, way back when, I used to watch
those Mail Unboxing, and-
- Oh, yeah?
- Those are my favorites,
- Dude,
those are so wild.
- I love those videos.
- I think, at that time,
it was something so unique
because, obviously, you
know big massive celebrities
would be getting this kind of stuff.
But I think it was the first
time that a normal person
could just watch somebody
receive all sorts of weird shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it was just like,
this is so weird.
(Joey laughs)
- It really did show you the
scope of like how strange
the common person can be with the items
that they choose to send you.
(hosts laugh)
And the drawings
that they choose to draw.
- That must have been weird.
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- Well, what was some
of the weirdest stuff
you ever got sent?
- I have some very good
go-tos for that, don't you worry.
- Okay, yes.
(hosts laugh)
- We got a Ziploc bag of dead bees.
- (laughs) What?
- I wanna know, how did
they collect those bees?
- They might not have been bees.
Maybe they look like bees,
- (laughs) Just insects.
- I did not examine enough
to know for sure.
(Garnt laughs)
We have a slightly smaller,
thinner bag of nail clippings.
- Oh.
- Yeah, yeah, everyone-
- Didn't you receive shit
as well at one point?
- We received stuff that smelled like shit
that we never ventured into, no.
- You didn't play with it,
you didn't play with it?
- Yeah, yeah,
I felt the texture.
(hosts laugh)
It's like, this is definitely
- Gave a little smell,
I don't know.
- elephant shit.
- It's definitely human shit.
(men laugh)
- We definitely had boxes,
and we received so many boxes
that we would sometimes
just throw it in our garage
and they would sit in the
humidity and the heat.
And it would be months
before we'd get to it.
And people thought it was so funny
that they would send us sandwiches.
And these sandwiches would just rot
and mold and-
- Oh my God.
- Oh, 'cause of like the
food fight stuff, I mean.
- I don't know of why,
but it became a thing.
And the bags, the Ziploc bags
would inflate with the gases
from these things, they would pop.
And then the scent would just permeate
throughout our entire house.
- Oh God.
- Yeah, you'd throw away
the boxes once they were
- You could see patches.
- kinda sopping wet
or oily or greasy.
But that quickly was like,
it's probably about time
to stop receiving the mail.
Like, it was fun, it
was a great time period.
- So how long did you guys do that for?
- I think we did it for
like three or four years.
- My God. My God.
- Was all the shit fucked?
- And by the end,
it was years of stuff just built up,
towers and towers of mail.
- My God.
I guess every now and then
you probably get something
really fucking cool that you're like,
"Yeah, this is sick."
- Yeah,
we would receive some really cool shit.
- Oh, man.
- Lots of used video games.
And then I would just
take 'em all to GameStop
and I'd be like, "Used video games."
(hosts laugh)
And then they'd be like, "$100 credit."
I was like, "Two games I actually want."
(hosts laugh)
- That's so big, but I didn't about it.
- Not like the eight copies
of the "Nintendogs Rip-Off's"
of like puppies
- Oh my God.
- and like all these weird
like ponies and cats with a Z.
(Connor laughs)
So many weird games that I
would never be interested
in playing, I was like,
"I can convert these
into games I wanna play."
(Joey laughs)
- It's just people just giving junk.
Are they just trying to get rid of it?
- Well, a lot of stuff that we were given
were just like, people are
looking for things to send.
- They're like, "I wanna
send you something."
- Yeah, and they didn't wanna
spend money on just sending
'cause they didn't even
know if we would see it.
There is no guarantee.
We didn't even know if we would see it.
In fact, some of the things I hope,
you know, it's probably
better off we didn't see
half of the things that we did see.
But people would send us just old stuff
that they wanted to throw away.
- Yeah, because that's-
- You coulda just started
a garage sale or
something, right? (laughs)
- It was like old shirts that
had not been washed in years
and had holes in it.
- Ooh.
- Yeah, because to them,
it was probably just like,
"Yo, that's my shirt is the video."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, you know?
- So then we had to start
being really selective
about the things that we showed.
We had to stop showing
- The weird shit.
- the shit stuff,
the dead stuff,
the body, human body.
- The human bodies.
- Anything that came from a human body
was no longer making it in
the videos to a certain point.
Yeah, we realized
- Ugh.
- that we were encouraging it.
And then we also accidentally
encouraged people
to send us money because we
had one video where someone,
a few people sent us like $1 bills,
so he's like, "Ooh, we
got 10 bucks," and like,
it was kind of a joke.
- Oh shit.
- And then we had to make
a ooh, we got 100 bucks.
And then it was like, we
need to stop showing money
all together.
- Yeah.
- And we realized that
anything that we showed
was a direct call for people
to send us more of it.
So eventually we had to
stop showing the weird stuff
or the really grandiose stuff
'cause we didn't feel
comfortable with either.
- Yeah, someone might feel bad
if you show off like
something really amazing.
And they're like, "Oh,
and I guess, Charlotte
from like Mexico sent me this
like shitty little keyring."
(men laugh)
- And a lot of people were
sending really sentimental
handwritten things that we could never,
like if I wanted to
read every one of those,
and I really wish I could
'cause they were so heartfelt,
it would've been a
full-time job to do that
instead of anything else.
Which is a great problem to have.
- I'm interrupting this
episode of "Trash Taste"
to give you an important announcement.
This "Trash Taste" episode
is sponsored by Bokksu.
Anyone who watches "Trash Taste"
will know that we are big fans of Bokksu.
If you haven't heard of it yet,
Bokksu is a monthly
subscription snack box service
that delivers premium Japanese
snacks and tea pairings
straight from Japan to your door.
The first Bokksu you will receive
is called Seasons of Japan.
Following the seasons of Japan,
you'll receive a new monthly themed box
every single month like this one.
And this one's theme is,
♪ Do, do, do ♪
oh, Onsen Vacation.
You know me and the boys
are always talking about
our onsen vacations,
and this theme, you can
get snacks from places
that are famous for their onsens.
Each Bokksu is packed with snacks
and it comes with a cultural booklet
that tells you all about the theme,
where the snacks come from,
details on all the flavors.
And it even teaches you a few
Japanese words and phrases.
Baka.
Now I would like to try, oh, yes.
Osenbei, it's a rice cracker
snack, and I love these.
(calm upbeat music)
(mouth crunches)
Mm, so if you wanna try
some rare Japanese snacks
and support Japanese family businesses
and support our channel, make sure to go
and order a Bukksu by smashing their link
in the inscription down below.
And don't forget to use
coupon code trashtaste15
to get $15 off your
very first Bokksu order.
Back to the episode.
- So you mentioned
like, you were one like,
pretty much one of the
first creatures to get paid
for doing what you do on YouTube.
When did you start to realize,
oh, this is serious now,
this is like gonna get big?
- I mean, it depends, there
were so many different levels
of big, like at that point,
I already felt like it was a big thing.
'Cause I was like, we are
one of the first people
to get paid on this platform
that I foresee as having longevity.
(exhales sharply) But in
terms of like, I don't know,
it was a little bit dicey though.
So that was 2007, and
then four years later,
I didn't really know what the
fate of YouTube was gonna be.
And we had an offer from a
company which ultimately,
you know, their name ended up being Defy.
And they offered us then to
buy our company for stock,
it was a totally great idea.
(hosts laugh)
- Well, you've talked about
this a lot in your video
about it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, obviously, didn't end
up being worth anything.
- So how did they pitch it to you
in a way that you both were like,
"Yeah, this is a fucking
great idea, let's do it,"
how did that happen?
- Yeah, you know, and it is a complicated
process, too,
- I imagine, yeah.
- Because, you know, the
state of YouTube in 2011,
it felt really like, we didn't
know where it was going.
- Was that before or
after the Google+ thing
they tried to shove in?
- Google+?
- Do you remember-
- No, that was 20,
that was when I first started,
so that was like 2014.
- Oh, oh.
- Yeah, that was ages
after that.
- Okay, okay, okay.
'Cause that just felt like everyone was-
- That was shit.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Google+ is when Google
tried to do Facebook and-
- Oh, yeah,
I forgot about it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was just a shit
show when it happened.
- I think it lasted like a year,
- Then they cut it.
- maybe,
and then they were like,
"Nah, we get rid of it."
- I get it that YouTube
has been constantly at,
especially in it's earlier days,
it did seem like it was like,
what the fuck is YouTube?
Yeah.
- It felt very fragile
for a while.
- Right.
- Yeah, so they presented it to us
as we're gonna take all
the website smash.com stuff
off your plate because I was
doing all of that myself,
because (laughs) I actually made money
before we started getting paid on YouTube
by designing websites for people.
And that's how I was able
to fund a lot of things
and side tangent.
Our videos actually started getting,
we made like two lip sync
videos before the Pokemon Theme.
(hosts laugh)
- If it works, it works, baby.
Keep it coming.
- Doing a little tester run.
(men laugh)
- Before we found out about YouTube
and I hosted it on my own website.
And 'cause there was
no website like YouTube
to host it on and stuff.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I created a little thing,
again, it was an eye frame,
you copy paste there.
And when you paste that to your page,
it had instructions and everything,
when you copy paste it
to your Myspace page,
it put the video there.
And then it also had
instructions to copy and paste
for someone else, that
was how I designed this
like a copy paste viral kind of thing.
And I didn't know how well that was doing
with the two lip sync videos,
(laughs) it's so weird to say,
(hosts laugh)
that we did beforehand.
But I did get a bill.
I did see the bill and it
was a couple hundred bucks,
you know?
And I didn't know how to
convert that into how many views
is this getting, but I knew
it was getting a lotta views
or else I wouldn't have to
pay a couple hundred dollars
for bandwidth on videos.
So you actually used to
have to pay for bandwidth
before YouTube offered the service.
So we found out about
YouTube by me doing a search
for one of the videos I found
that someone else had uploaded
it to YouTube, and I sent 'em a message.
I was like, "Hey, this video,
thank you so much for uploading it here.
We wanna upload it ourselves,
do you mind removing it?"
And they said, "Yeah, absolutely."
So we created our channel.
"Smosh" was still five
letters, still available.
And that was the beginning of that.
- Damn.
- Shoot, (laughs)
I forgot where we were going.
We were going with why Defy.
- He asked you about-
- Why did defy, like how
did that all come around?
- How did they pitch it to you?
- Yes, okay, okay, yeah.
Okay, I got off on a side tangent
because I was talking about
how I designed the website.
(hosts laugh)
- "Trash Taste" is all
about tangents, don't worry.
- We always have tangents.
- You're fitting right in,
right in.
- Oh, yeah, it's seamless.
So they came to us and they were like,
"We will take care of the website
so you no longer have
that stress to deal with."
'Cause every week the website was crashing
and I was figuring out how to keep it up.
And they had this huge
plan of all the things
that they were capable of and how they had
the infrastructure to allow
us to do all of our dreams.
So they asked us, "What do you
wanna do with this company?
If you could make this company
anything, what would it be?"
And we had these huge lofty goals.
They said, "We got all of that on lock.
We have the infrastructure,
we have the investors,
we could make this happen."
And they offered us a certain
amount of money in stock.
It sounded really good.
More money than I thought that, you know,
I would ever see in my life before that.
So I was like, "That sounds great."
Obviously, this company's
eventually gonna go public.
That's how they work, right?
I did not know, my lawyer did not tell me
that that's not always the case.
The people that we had surrounding us
that were authority
figures in some way to us,
on the situation did not
break down the details
of how that doesn't always happen
and how that's actually a huge risk.
- Yeah, yeah, of course.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So they bought full ownership
and they paid us in yearly,
you know, annual salaries.
And they had this structure
set up where it was like,
this year, eh, it's a
pretty shitty salary,
but next year, it's an okay salary.
But by year four, you're
gonna love your salary.
So-
- Did that happen?
- It did eventually play out that way.
And I was pretty comfortable with it.
I was like, we are making
a good salary here.
Like, what do we really
have to complain about?
- And I guess they're
doing a lot of the stuff
that you used to have to do
and they're looking for
things and managing it.
But then also I imagine as a YouTuber,
it's probably quite difficult
to give that control
to someone else.
- It was, because I did
give that control away
and everything was not
how I woulda done it.
So I ended up working
double time to teach them
how to do the things, but
then they were rehiring.
And the way that bigger companies work
is just like, you're never just building
a one-on-one relationship with someone
who like you teach 'em once and they know,
and they keep going with that thing.
And then it's just a
thing that happens now.
It's like, no, you're reteaching
and reteaching and
reteaching until it's like,
okay, let's abandon the website.
And then it was like me
abandoning a lot of the things
that I had a dream of growing
because I was not able to keep that up
and also do the videos.
So, you know, I had to figure
out where to put my time.
- Yeah, was there a specific point
when you kind of realized, damn,
this is not what I envisioned
at all and I kinda want out?
Like, was there a specific moment
or was it just like a build
up of a lot of things?
- It was primarily a buildup
over a long period of time.
It was about four years in when I realized
that things just weren't looking right.
And I still had two years
on the contract left.
And I think one particular thing was like,
they hired someone that I did not know
that they were gonna hire.
And then all of a sudden I found out
that they were now a full-time employee
in this really important position
that meant something to me.
And I was like, "Wait, I didn't realize
that was what was gonna happen."
And also, there were times,
and I don't know how much I could say,
but I'll see what I can do.
(men laugh)
- Well, they don't exist
anymore, right, so.
- True, technically.
There was a fundraiser that they put on.
- Oh.
- It was for a game.
And they had just seen the
success of other people
who had done fundraisers for games,
Indiegogo,
- Oh, you're right.
- GoFundMe type things.
And they raised like
$250,000 for these games,
which were like mobile games,
but you could play it on the computer.
And it was like this really cool thing
with all these inside
jokes from the community.
And they said, "Oh, that's
cool, guy, you do that."
And then we were like, "We don't
have a concept for a game."
They're like, "Ah, we'll
figure it out later.
You just raise some money."
- Oh, what, so they
just made the fundraiser.
And then afterwards, they
were like, "Make the game."
- And we said, "We need to have something
to pitch to people, we need."
And then they were like, "Cool, well,
just tell 'em the idea then."
And then they were like,
"You come up with the idea."
So I came up with the
idea, Ian, of course, also.
We both came up with the idea.
And they were like, "Cool, you
got the idea, let's do it."
And I was like, "We need
to have concept art,
we need to like show a build of the game.
We need to be able to show
what we want to do with this thing."
And they were like,
"Ah, we don't have time.
Okay, we'll get concept art."
So all we were able to do was
launch with this concept art.
- Wow.
- Oh my God.
- And launching a campaign, asking people,
incentivizing your fans to give you money,
well, it did not feel right to me,
but I felt backed up into a corner.
And, you know, I think that's
probably one of the things
that I regret from my time there,
is allowing myself to feel
backed up into a corner,
to accept money from
people that were excited
about this thing being built.
Of course, you know, we
did accept money for that.
And I did put all of my heart and soul
into making it as good
as it possibly could be,
still didn't live up to my expectations.
And I feel like if it was done
the right way, it would've.
But the moment that really stood out to me
was there was some
shadiness about, you know,
obviously the way that
they pushed to earn money
for something because
they saw dollar signs.
- Right, not because it was good projects.
- Rather than it being
like, those types of things,
if you're gonna have
your audience fund them,
it should really be a passion project.
- Absolutely.
- Exactly.
- And I could have made
it a passion project
'cause I really was excited about it,
but it was so forced and rushed.
And then there was some shady stuff
about like the way that they contributed
to certain donations to inflate
- Huh.
- the way that
certain things looked.
And that's really all I'll say about that,
but it made me feel so weird about it.
I was like, "I need out
as soon as possible."
- I imagine when they were
doing stuff like that,
the confidence you had in the company
was probably a bit like,
okay, if they're willing
to do this, stuff must
not be going so great.
- And I realized that the
way that they treated that
was the same way that
they were treating me
and all the other people.
- Because a lotta people
lost a lot of money, right,
I mean, it was like crazy.
- What was it?
- A lot of people lost
a lot of money on YouTube.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, eventually.
Luckily, I wouldn't
say I foresaw anything,
but it didn't feel right.
And I got out a year before
they ended up closing down.
And another thing that
really was a turning point
was I had made a Facebook
page and it was, I don't know,
I had like 500, 600,000 followers
or whatever you call it on Facebook.
- It's just like Anthony.
- Subscribers.
- Friends.
- Friends, friends, yes.
(men laugh)
And, yeah, it was "Smosh" Anthony.
And they were like, "Oh,
this has "Smosh" in the name,
so we're gonna run this for you, okay?"
I was like, "Okay, yeah, yeah, sure."
And then I was like, hey, you know,
I was kinda trying to start
to silently transition out.
I think they kinda picked up on the gist
'cause we still were
contractually obligated.
But I was like, "Can I
get my Facebook back?"
They're like, "No, it's ours."
I was like-
- Oh.
- Oh!
- "But I made that thing.
And you said that you
just wanted to run it
because you were gonna help
me post content on there."
They're like, "It has "Smosh" in the name,
this is ours."
- (gasps) That's fucked up.
- I was like, "Okay."
- Geez.
- And then I easily settled on that.
I was like, "Oh, okay, it's fine.
It's just Facebook, who
cares, it's Facebook."
And then they were like,
"Okay, hey, can we get
access to your Twitter
and Instagram?"
(Connor inhales sharply)
I was like, "No."
- (laughs) No.
- What the fuck?
- And then I immediately
changed the name from "Smosh"
Anthony to Anthony Padilla
(hosts laugh)
- Not on my watch!
- after they asked me
for access to that.
- In a way, it's kind of cool
that they kind of forced you
into being like, "You know what?
Fuck this, I'm just gonna go on my own.
Like, I'm gonna fucking brand myself.
Fuck these guys."
- It really got me thinking
like, could I do something
- Could I do this?
- on my own outside of this
brand that I had created?
Yeah, and it was really sad
because I had made that brand,
- "Smosh" was yours, yeah.
- when I was 14 years old,
I made that as like a
little shitty website,
as like a forum for me and
my group of friends at school
to go on and hang out with each other.
It was really before social media,
it was like, we were either talking on AIM
or we were going onto this website.
And, yeah, it was sad to
kinda let that part of me,
this baby that I had brought
into this world, kinda go.
- Yeah, God, it must be nerve-racking
trying to do something
yourself though, right?
- Yeah.
- Because as a YouTuber
starting, ditching your channel,
which has like millions and
millions of subscribers,
to start from the ground up again.
I think like you were one
of the first people I know,
like the first big creators,
to really like branch off
and try to do something themselves
with a new channel, right?
- And it succeeded.
- And doing well.
- And there wasn't a precedent
set before that really
that you could really succeed
by doing something new, right?
- Right, I mean, well, Fred did it.
- Oh.
- Oh, yeah.
- Fred had another channel
and then he did his thing.
- That's true, that's true.
- Well, he did a few movies.
You had a few movies too.
- I did a movie.
- How was doing a movie?
- How was doing a movie,
ah, man.
(hosts laugh)
That was also another weird experience.
- But a part of me, 'cause,
obviously, I mean, do you,
(laughs) it's not a good movie.
(men laugh)
I was just, ah, fuck it,
I was trying to think of how to say it.
It's not a good movie.
But it's-
- My heart, no, no.
I put my heart and soul into that movie,
it's the best movie.
- Wow, right in front of him?
- Oh my God.
- I feel like-
- This is up fucked up.
- It's a part of you-
- We invite him onto the show.
- You invite me on here to talk
shit about my pride and joy?
- Listen, I wanna talk to you,
answer me then.
- Did you actually watch that?
- Yeah, I loved it.
- Dear lord, wait,
- I love it in a way of like-
- (laughs) you said
you loved it?
- Yeah, it's a terrible movie.
(men laugh)
- It's so fucking bad.
- It's like it's so bad that it's good.
- Yeah, but it's that amazing
part of YouTube history
where like everyone had to have a movie.
YouTube for some reason was like,
"Make a fucking movie, pop them out."
Fred had fucking John Cena in his movie.
(all chattering)
- Oh, yeah. (laughs)
- I completely forgot about that.
- Dude.
- It was just a fucking cool,
weird time where people were
making movies, whereas like,
I mean, did you even wanna make a movie?
Was it like, what was that,
what was going on with that?
'Cause I feel like there
must have been so many people
trying to put their things in there,
trying to be like, "No, it should be this,
it should be this."
"No, no, no, fuck, well,
should get John Cena in it."
"Well, I don't know, it's John Cena."
- Oh, we got "Stone
Cold" Steve Austin in it.
- Oh, yeah.
- Well, there you go.
"We gotta get someone from the WWE."
(men laugh)
- Well, it was like, "John
Cena's not happening.
It's gonna be "Stone Cold" Steve Austin."
- Yeah, I wanna know about the movie.
Like, what was all that?
(laughs) You know?
- Yeah.
So we, I mean, yeah, a lotta
people had movies going on
and a lotta people were
breathing down our neck saying,
"So when are you gonna make a movie?"
And we did kind of have this
dream of eventually making
the movie version of our "Smosh" sketch.
And we had a lot of, nothing concrete,
but like, ooh, what
would the movie version
of this look like?
If we get $1 million, do we...
We had some of the dumbest
ideas of like where the movie
was all a "Smosh" sketch budget.
And then we had millions
of dollars worth of money
pumped into the final scene.
(men laugh)
That was our initial idea.
- No, because I remember
on the "Smosh" channel,
this was way before the
actual movie came out,
you guys released an April Fool's video
called "Smosh the Movie."
- Yeah, yeah, we did.
- Have you seen this video?
- I think I've watched this.
- This was like the first ever
- That was a long time ago,
right?
- April Fool's YouTube video
that I saw, but it was
like the first five minutes
was the most insane quality,
(Anthony laughs)
like, oh my God, this looks like a movie.
And then the remaining hour
and a half was you and Ian
walking back home with no cuts.
And I thought this is
the greatest thing ever.
So then when I heard that
you guys were actually making
a movie, I was like, so psyched.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- So psyched, it's just
another variable fortune.
- I must say,
for YouTuber movies, it was the,
oh, what was the name of
the one with the ghost?
Wait.
- "Ghostmates?"
- "Ghostmates," that was probably
- Oh, "Ghostmates."
- one of the better
YouTuber movies, I will say,
that one was good, right?
- That one we had
a little bit more freedom with
and in a weird way though,
we almost stripped out a lot of what made
"Smosh" "Smosh" with that movie.
So it felt weird 'cause it wasn't quite,
you know, a good movie
and then it wasn't quite
a bad YouTube movie,
which is also entertaining
for its own reasons.
- I think it's 'cause
you and Ian are, I think,
naturally very good on camera.
Like, compared to how some
other people transitioned
to the movies kinda thing.
I think you and Ian did that a lot better.
- Aw, thanks.
- Well, I think it
definitely helped that you
guys were already acting
in your sketches.
- Yeah.
- There's a lot of that going on.
- Acting.
(men laugh)
Acting in your sketches.
- I heard a lot about how
I should improve my acting
in the comments, but-
- Really?
- Oh, yeah.
- 'Cause they're gonna go
into it and they're gonna be like,
"You're a YouTuber, you can't act."
So even if you did an amazing job,
people would be like-
- Like, stay in your lane.
- "No, no, no."
- There's an expectation.
Yeah, but with the movies,
you know, with the first one,
it was a lot of, you know, we
did have this dream to do it,
but then other people,
you know, it was at Defy.
They were like, "We
need to make this happen
and we need to make it
happen in four months."
(Connor exhales sharply)
- Four months?
- Okay, I'm just throwing
a random number.
- Ah!
- Okay, I was about to say.
- But it was too soon.
- But it was something
too little.
- Too soon.
- Not enough time, not enough time.
- It coulda been six,
it coulda been eight,
but I think it was somewhere
probably around six months.
- Jesus.
- And we were like,
actually, no, I remember it
was after we got to a point
in the scriptwriting
process that they said
this needs to happen in this
very short amount of time.
We're like, "We're not ready.
Well, we're still like
fleshing this thing out."
And it was a thing where we
still wanted to make our videos
on YouTube, we didn't wanna give that up.
'Cause we felt like we
would've had to dropped that
in order to put all of our
effort into making a movie.
And they were like, "Don't
worry, we can hire this person."
And they gave us a few
options, they hired a person.
The script was not anything
like I woulda wanted it to be.
It was a lot of like-
- Shoulda done one on Fiverr.
(men laugh)
We found a guy.
- Yeah, who is this guy?
It was a lot of like here's what someone
who isn't in the YouTube
space thinks our videos
and thinks YouTube is.
- Was it someone who worked in like,
you know, Hollywood movies?
- It was like a Hollywood scriptwriter
who did like TV series and
I think some movies as well.
And he did do some funny stuff,
but it was very much like
an outta touch perspective.
And it was like, I mean,
a lot of "Smosh" stuff was
cringing in its own right.
But like I was cringing at how outta touch
these things were, it's like
I could not do these things.
There was this area where
like memes go to die
that was written where it was
like a space-
- I remember this.
- Was that in the movie?
- I don't know,
fuck, now was it, fuck,
- I don't this it was-
- it just sounds so familiar.
- You know, I think that
Ian mighta talked about it
on a separate thing.
- Okay, that's probably why
this sounds so familiar.
- Or maybe he and I both
talked about it at some point,
but there was this part
written where it was like,
where memes go to die.
And he was like, "Tazuna's in there."
And I was like, "Okay, first of all,
you're trying to make us say
that these people are dead memes."
(hosts laugh)
- This sounds so familiar.
- That's kinda fucked up.
And then also you are saying,
here's all these things
that are not in the now, it's
just this weird period piece
that just feels too soon
to be a period piece.
You know what I mean?
- Also it might age poorly.
- Yeah.
- It also just sounds
like a "Hello, Fellow
Children" moment, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It's like, yes,
I know memes, I know meme culture.
These are doing right.
- It was exactly like that.
- Hillary Clinton, am I right?
(men laugh)
- It felt a lot like that.
And then we did a lot of rewrites
and it was still a very bad movie.
(men laugh)
- Oh, my bad.
Maybe I was a little too harsh.
- How self-aware were
you on set to be like,
"Guys, are we making
a bad movie?"
- I think I was
half self-aware.
- Right, right.
- I wasn't fully self-aware,
part of me thought, like after
a certain scene happened,
I was like, "Oh, that
might actually be good."
Part of me did think it might
actually be a good movie
depending on the way it was cut,
depending on the way the
special effects look.
But the way that it came
together was very much,
after we were seeing
like final cuts of it,
I was like, "Okay,
(hosts laugh)
that's, um,
- Can I get a reshoot?
- that's the movie."
- Well, I mean, at least it's not as bad
as Shane Dawson's movie,
that was-
- Yeah.
- I mean, it depends who you ask 'cause-
- No, that one was really, really bad.
- Was it?
- Have you seen it?
- I did, but I saw it like
- Years ago.
- on the premier night
where there was so much hype in the room
from all the friends and
family that it was hard to tell
is this a funny joke
or am I just not in a
good head space right now?
You know what I mean?
(hosts laugh)
- You should go rewatch it sometime.
- Maybe I will.
- It's interesting.
- Okay, okay.
- I never even tried that one.
No, no, no.
- It's not good.
- Okay, okay.
- Geez.
- Well, it was a lot of fun though.
And I think that some elements
from the "Smosh" sketches
retained their Smoshiness.
- Yeah, I mean, it's much
easier for me to sit here
and be like, "You made a fucking movie."
(men laugh)
Like I could do any fucking movie.
Like my movie would be good. (laughs)
"Oh, you gotta make it in six."
"What? I can't even spell."
- It was a weird process
because, you know,
we had trailers, and we had
- Oh.
- an acting coach, and we
had the pressure of like,
this is the movie.
It was something like $1 million budget.
So it was like-
- You got like
the full Hollywood experience.
- It was the full
Hollywood experience.
- Damn.
- And, you know, we had
like a writer there on set
to do rewrites in the moment
if we needed to rewrite
something for time.
And there were a lotta
scenes that we had to cut
for time and they were rewritten on them.
It was such a different
experience, where it was not,
like I could still go to the
director, who was Alex Winter
and he's amazing, you know?
- Yeah.
- Is he the Bill?
I forget if he's the Bill or Ted
from "Bill & Ted's Excellent Adventure,"
but not Keanu Reeves,
- Oh, wow, really?
- but, you know the-
- Oh, he's the Ted, I think.
- Ted, Ted, no, Bill, Bill.
- I don't know.
The one that's not Keanu.
- That sounds awesome.
- But Alex Winter's amazing.
And, you know, his kids
were huge fans of "Smosh"
so he really did want to give it that
genuine "Smosh" feel.
- Dude, I feel bad
for calling it bad.
(men laugh)
It's got all this heart and passion,
and I just thought it was bad.
- It was shit.
- No matter how much heart and passion
you put into something, if
there are a few elements
that are slightly off,
it's gonna all feel,
it's gonna kinda all get
brought down to that level.
And I feel like that's what happened.
There were a lot of great
things that could have been,
but then it was like,
there were certain elements
that just kinda brought it all down
to this weird level.
- I've been hearing,
"Oh, we're gonna cut the
scene 'cause of time,"
that doesn't make you
probably feel very confident.
You're like, "That's not good."
- Yeah, yeah, but, you know,
a lotta times we're like,
we're gonna cut this scene for time
and we end up having this other scene
that totally actually
works fine without it,
- Oh, that was okay.
- and it was like
the rewrites were okay.
- Were you're sketches before scripted,
so you already were used
to memorizing lines,
or were you like mostly improvised before?
- Yeah, yeah, they were
definitely scripted.
But usually we would like
get a take that we like,
and then we'd be like go
off book for the final take.
And like half the time we'd
go with the off book version.
But it was a little bit
different, so "Smosh" videos,
we would shoot, you know,
10 second clips of like this thing.
Okay, you say this thing.
And when you do a movie,
they really want you to
get like the full scene
with this angle, then the full
scene with the next angle.
- No jump cuts. No
fucking jump cuts, yeah.
- Continuity.
- Yeah.
- So a lot of the acting
in it was actually me
trying to remember my lines,
and if I watch it,
(hosts laugh)
I'm just like, I'm just trying to remember
my lines right now.
(hosts laugh)
For most of these lines,
like it didn't really get past that.
And also I got in my
head a lot about like,
I don't think this is gonna be the movie
that I wished it could be.
- That would be so hard
to like really turn up
and give it your all
when it just doesn't feel
- It was hard.
- like it's going right.
It was like after the first day,
even though there were so many people
that had a lot of passion
and good intentions
and a lotta people that
did put their heart
and soul into it, after
the first day I was like,
this doesn't feel like it's gonna be
what I thought it would be.
And then it was hard to get out of my head
and get out of that head space.
- And I guess you couldn't
exactly go to Defy
and be like, "Hey,
(men laugh)
can we change?"
- Yeah.
- It's not like a YouTube
video where you-
- Hey, we just shot
the first day.
- Yeah. (laughs)
It's like this guy kind of isn't working,
let's scrap and go to a new YouTuber.
Let's do a new video, you know?
- Yeah, yeah, well, even
down to the sketches,
it was hard to say this video didn't work.
- Oh, really?
- Oh, shit.
- Because there was a lotta money
that was invested into it.
- Damn.
- And we were given a
certain budget each month.
And if we scrapped it, it would be like,
this is cutting into our overall budget.
Let's just try to make this work.
- Oh, right.
- So when that pressure
starts building up and you
have all these other eyes
and voices and budgets and restrictions,
that's when I think things
start to kinda go south
in those situations.
And that's when I started
to feel like things
weren't really right.
Even though I could totally
see why you can't reshoot
a sketch after you shoot it.
Obviously, it makes sense.
But I think if I was fully independent,
there were a lotta things
that I might have considered reshooting.
But when we have this level
where we want the
production value to be there
and we kinda reach that point,
it felt weird to go back.
I now know that you could
go back and it's fine, but.
(men laugh)
- Back then you're like, "Holy shit."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Damn.
- Would you ever want
to make another movie
with the correct amount of
time and creative freedom?
- Oh, man.
- Anthony Padilla the Movie.
(men laugh)
- It's just me now.
- This is you.
- It's just him interviewing.
- Oh, man.
I don't know, I don't
have any drive for that.
I have been pushing myself more
with the intros of my videos
on my channel that I
do now, it is scripted.
And I realize that none of the passion
that goes into me writing the
words makes it on the camera
when I'm recording these intros.
- Yeah, of course.
- So now I'm trying to,
in a sense, maybe I'm
like reverse-engineering
a way for me to learn how to act
is by just actually giving
the emotions that I,
when I write these things,
for me to actually give the emotions.
I'm like, "Oh, when you say a line
you're supposed to visualize it."
(hosts laugh)
Oh!
- You're not just saying it.
- You don't just say the word?
Oh, that's what acting is.
So in a weird backward sense,
I feel like I am pushing myself to learn
how to act a little bit.
And maybe, you know, it depends.
It depends, but right now, no.
(men laugh)
No, no, no, no.
- Yeah, you've kind of done
so much in the time that
you've been on YouTube.
Like, is there anything you haven't done
that you want to do
eventually down the line?
'Cause I feel like, when
you just think about
even just "Smosh" stuff,
it's like, you guys have
literally been at the top,
you've done everything, you've done
all the big stuff.
- Been at the top twice.
- They've been at the top twice, dude.
And you've done the movies,
you've done, you know,
did you release a book?
- We released a graphic novel,
- Ah.
- yeah, yeah,
I had a lotta fun making it.
Most people don't even know that existed
'cause they did not market it.
But I put my heart and
soul into a graphic novel,
but no actual book, so that's something
I never have done.
- Is that something
you'd wanna try, or is
there like something else
where you're just like eventually
I'd like to do it?"
- Maybe, maybe.
I thought about putting together
some kind of coffee table book
that goes through the
different interviews I've done
and talks about the different things
that I learned from each interview.
The things that I've taken from that
and been able to apply to my own life.
And the moments that stood
out to me as key things
that I now go back to and think about.
- Yeah, so an autobiography.
(men laugh)
- A little bit,
- In a sense.
- but hopefully it could be
also a way for people to
learn through me learning.
Like, that's part of why I do
the interview series now.
- I mean, to be fair,
if there's anyone who has enough material
to write a cohesive
autobiography, it's you.
- (laughs) I don't know.
I feel like putting it in
the term of autobiography,
I'm like, "Ah, ah, no, no, no."
(all chattering)
- Why is bad?
- It's 'cause
you're self-important.
Somehow you'll say I know so much more
than you'll read about
in the fucking handbooks.
- It's cause we've seen
the YouTubers who have
written autobiographies,
and you're just like come on.
- Hi, I'm 24.
(men laugh)
This is my life, man.
- I struggled 12 times in my life.
(men laugh)
- That's what I've always-
- And I've recognized
eight of them.
- Yeah, exactly.
- This video is sponsored by Tippsy.
- Tippsy is a quarterly
subscription sake box
where you'll get six curated sake bottles
straight from Japan
- Ooh.
- to try all sorts of
pairings and dishes with.
- Guys, come on, you know you wanna try
some new sake, right, come on.
- Well, why don't you guys try some out
while I give you some pointers?
- Well, luckily, Joe, we
have some custom sake boxes
that we made just for my wedding.
- Oh my Lord.
- I know.
- Get the full Japanese
experience with that.
- I actually get to use
it this time.
(Joey laughs)
- So the one that Connor
is drinking right now
is the Toyo Bijin,
this particular brew
gives an aroma red apple
that fades to an almost nutmeg spice.
It's a very dry sake,
it's said to be strong
enough to kill a devil.
- That's actually quite nice actually.
- Yeah, I told you. (laughs)
- Yeah, it's good.
That's good.
- Ooh,
what am I drinking, Joey?
- Well, Garnt, you're drinking
the Kinoene Junmai Ginjo,
the sake itself is bursting
with enticing aroma
and pristine flavor that
hints of freshly sliced apple
and a crisp finish.
- That's actually really good.
So, guys, if you want some amazing deals
in your starter kit,
then you get can 10% off all products
using code trashtaste10.
- And you can get $30
off your first sake box
by using trashtaste30.
- Is that two coupon codes?
- That's two coupons codes.
- My lord.
- That is two different deals,
- Smash that link down below.
- guys.
- Smash that link.
- Back to the episode.
- I have to ask 'cause I'm curious,
'cause you've been on YouTube for so long,
sorry, do you hate when people
say stuff like that?
- No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
- You're such
a fucking dinosaur, dude.
- I just think about my age.
It's fine.
- You're a YouTube boomer,
dude.
(men laugh)
- 'Cause, you know,
YouTube has gone through
a lot of distinct eras, I'd say,
do you have a favorite YouTube era
where you felt like
this is when it was peak
YouTube?
- The golden time of YouTube.
- Yeah, yeah, I think it was
probably around like 2011
to 2013-ish, where there
was money to be made,
and sponsors, like people
would take it seriously enough
to fund everything.
But yet there wasn't this idea
that like mainstream media had
of like anyone can do this
and become a millionaire.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I feel like it was
still very independent
and it just felt like creativity
was what thrived most.
- Yeah, because I feel
like that era of YouTube,
all of the biggest creators at that time,
they all started YouTube
not to make money.
But just because they enjoyed
the creativeness of it.
They enjoyed making videos.
And then I feel like after
that, it kinda progressed
into people realizing that
you could make this a job.
- Absolutely.
- And you could like,
people did it for the money.
- And it could be a business.
- Yeah, it's a legitimate business,
which is nothing wrong with that.
But I feel like part of
the magic was lost, I feel,
you know?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause it kinda transitioned
into something else,
you know, it-
- Yeah, a different mindset
going into creating things.
And around that time or soon after
is when I think the
algorithm was introduced.
- Ah, yes.
- The elusive algorithm.
- The algorithm.
- The one God of YouTube. (laughs)
- I'm learning more now that the algorithm
really does reward the things
that people enjoy consuming most.
And the algorithm's goal,
while no one individual
knows everything in and out
'cause it's made by so many
people and it's taught to learn.
That's not scary, don't worry.
- That's not so good.
- It's sent here.
(men laugh)
- That's not so good at all.
- The algorithm does reward the things
that do have the highest
retention, they have people,
you know, watching for the longest time,
replaying the moments most,
the highest click-through rate
of what looks most exciting.
So I am learning that you
can work with the new way
that it's set up, but it
was definitely jarring
when it first happened and no one knew
or was told what was happening.
- Just like flip to Let's Play overnight.
- Yeah, yeah, because
that was the fastest way
to make repeating long form content
that people would feel the
need to watch entirely.
- Oh, yeah, 'cause did you
guys start the gaming channel
around that time, or was it?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Is that why 'cause of the change
or was it just-
- We didn't know
what the reason was that
these videos were popping up,
but we saw, oh, wait, gaming videos,
that's becoming really popular.
People wanna see this and a lotta people
are asking us to play a game.
- I get it,
I'm a gamer, I'm a gamer.
- Yeah, I'm a gamer.
I could do it.
- Did you have a hard time
when the algorithm did shift
and you were still on
like, you know, scripted,
you know, script, sorry, scripted sketches
and everything like that?
- Yeah, yeah.
It was definitely a hard period.
I mean, it didn't really
affect us as much as-
- Yeah, you were probably
(all chattering)
still going pretty strong.
- We were still fine.
I looked recently and we still
have like a lot of videos
from that time that have like
10s of millions of views,
so it was okay.
It was okay, but it definitely did impact
the way that the videos
were pushed out initially.
So like after the first weekend,
I remember having a higher
up breathing down my neck
saying, "You guys usually
get a million views
in the first three days,
what's going on, why are?"
- Oh, no.
- You know, and it was a lot
of like this stress of like what is going?
And we're like, "I don't know, we-"
- You don't want a fucking
boss telling you that.
That's the last thing you want.
- And like their entire company
and all the X amount of
employees, like their livelihoods
are built on the
performance of these videos.
So at that time we were
really pushed to break off
and create other side channels
and experiment with longer form content,
- Jesus Christ.
- things that required
less editing.
- I feel so lucky being just like
a almost independent,
- Always been independent,
basically, yeah.
- like a one, two man team
with my own like personal channel,
because the pressure's
just gone, you know?
- It's a lot less pressure.
- Yeah, okay, so, 'cause like I gotta ask
'cause I rarely meet someone
who's been on YouTube for longer than me.
- For longer than most
of your viewers lives.
- Yeah, because, what?
(men laugh)
- Honestly.
- What a disturbing way
of putting it.
- Honestly, yeah.
- I just interviewed Nihachu,
who's like this really
popular Twitch streamer,
and she's 19, and I was
like, "So I made my,
been on YouTube when you were two?"
- Oh my God.
- And it freaked me out.
- That's scary.
- It freaked me the fuck out.
- 'Cause I found out today actually,
that today, out of complete coincidence,
is my 15th year anniversary on YouTube.
- Oh, shit.
- You've been on a long time.
(all chattering)
- You did it!
- Congratulations.
- So like I rarely get to ask this,
so what is the secret to stay
relevant for a long period
of time on YouTube?
(Anthony exhales sharply)
- You're asking that?
- You've been on for 15 years!
- Because you've been
on for longer than me,
so you're the only one that I can ask
for a actual perspective, right.
- Okay, okay, well, we could
share perspectives here
because I think that you might
have something to contribute
for 15 years.
- Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I'll be Mr. 17.
- 17, gonna talk
to my senior, my senior now.
- My YouTube career can
watch an R-rated movie,
but it can't quite vote or smoke.
(men laugh)
- Mine's in high school, you know?
- Okay, yeah, yeah, chilling.
- Yours is gonna be legal
next year, you know?
- You're getting
your first zits and trying
to be very uncomfortable
about it.
- Your balls are dropping.
(men laugh)
- You're very uncomfortable about puberty.
You're starting to get the
hang of it, no pun intended.
But let's see, so the secret,
the secret is to never feel
like you have it figured out.
- Right, yeah.
- The secret, I think,
is to always feel like there
is something new to learn.
I am constantly looking at the people
that are growing audiences and
I'm kinda filtering it out,
okay, this person, they have a recipe
and it pleases the algorithm.
I think, maybe that's why they have views.
Okay, what can I learn from that?
Okay, this person has a
really dedicated fan base,
they don't necessarily
appeal to the algorithm,
but they appeal to an audience,
and what can I learn from them?
So for me, it's really
about constantly learning.
And when I do interviews
with bigger names,
tomorrow I'm interviewing TommyInnit,
- Wow.
- Oh, nice, nice.
- And, you know, he's like, is he 18?
- He just graduated.
- He's still in school,
right, or was he-
- He's just graduated.
But, like, I love picking his brain
and, you know, people
that are new and coming up
on YouTube right now, and learning
what they see in the platform now,
because it's something
completely different.
And I feel like there is never a point,
where you as a creator on the internet
where things are so rapidly changing,
there is never a point
where you will be like,
"Figured it out."
And I used to think there would be a point
that I would be like, I gotta
grind and grind and grind,
and eventually I'll have it figured out
and then I'll just be able to sit back
and let the thing just live on its own.
And I think that's kinda what got me into,
or convinced me that like
selling to a company in 2011
was the right idea, I had it in my head.
The goal is to figure this
out, it'll go on autopilot.
I can relax and maybe do
other things in my life.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- But what I quickly realized
is that I really love doing this
and this is part of my
life that I want to retain.
And there will never be a point
where I feel satisfied just relaxing.
But also, if you sit back
and relax, then, you know,
and it's about like-
- You get comfortable.
- Yeah, you get comfortable
and you lose track
of why things are moving in
the direction they're going,
and what is relevant
to the platform today.
- Yeah, because that's
really interesting to hear
because from your perspective,
you've really like been
one of the top creators
basically since the birth of YouTube.
Whereas I've been on
YouTube for a long time,
but it's been like on a
very, very niche topic,
which is anime.
So I've always been able to learn
from what the bigger creators are doing.
And try to apply what
everyone else is doing.
And seeing if I can take
that into my own niche,
my own channel, and seeing
if it can grow out of there.
- And how has that paid off?
Like, were you able to take those lessons
and things that you learned
from the bigger YouTubers
and apply it to yourself
and have it pay off?
- Yeah, I mean, it kinda felt
like a cheat sheet, you know,
it kinda felt like cheating.
'Cause I'm just like, you
know, I'm in such a niche topic
that I can just take what
other people are doing
and just put it with my own content.
But with you, since
you're one of the people
setting the standards, you
know, one of the people
that I watch, and I was like, okay,
let's see what "Smosh" are doing.
Let's see what some of the other
bigger creatures are doing.
I'm like, okay, well, I see
what's successful to them.
But I feel like being at
the top of the pyramid
and trying to balance
yourself is a lot easier
than climbing up from
the bottom of the pyramid
- For sure.
- and trying to stay relevant.
- For sure, yeah.
I think that some people have a goal
of like get to the top of this pyramid,
just stay afloat up here.
And, of course, it is
much more comfortable
because you have the
freedom to kind of apply
more of these things that
you learn on a bigger scale.
But at the same time, there's
so much more pressure.
And I think that that's
unforeseen to smaller creators.
You know, I had my period,
I left "Smosh" when,
I think, we had 22 or
23 million subscribers,
huge amount of subscribers,
huge amount of pressure.
I go off and do my own thing.
Channel starts with a couple million.
And they're people that don't
really know what to expect.
I don't know what to give them.
And there was still that
pressure there from me
of how am I going to
entertain these people
who expect me to be giving
the quality of content
of a 22 million subscriber channel,
but now it's just me?
It's literally just me on my own.
- I'm really curious about,
obviously, a lot of the viewers,
when you said, ah, I'm leaving "Smosh,"
I think a lot of people
would see that and think,
oh, he's just leaving a channel.
But I imagine there was a lot
of probably behind the scenes
or like friendships that
were strained by that.
Was that like a, outside of
just the business perspective,
did that put a lotta strain
on like your personal life,
leaving that and having to kinda be like,
"All right, I'm leaving this big thing."
'Cause obviously Ian is there
and a bunch of your friends worked there.
- Well, surprisingly, me
leaving didn't put a strain
in and of itself, like
the idea of me leaving
and then me leaving.
That didn't exactly put a strain.
I think, maybe afterwards
it did a little bit,
really, I think it was
because audiences or viewers
and commenters really were
having all these different things
that they were saying about like,
"Oh, this person's better,"
or, "This person's better."
Or, "You were better when you were here,"
or, "They're better
now that they're here."
And I think that that
added a little bit of,
it was unavoidable to see those
especially-
- Oh, yeah, yeah.
- I feel like you can't
turn off your brain
from wanting to keep up with the comments,
if you're not even
trying to look for them.
- Yeah, you see, yeah.
- I'm trying to see
what people are thinking
about this new thing
that I'm just like trying to figure out.
And then I'm getting inundated
with all these opinions
from people, and I think
that that does seep in
when you're not ready for it.
I do wish that I was more ready
for the types of comments-
- How the fuck can you be ready for that?
(men laugh)
- The only way to be ready for it,
I think, is to live in it.
But I also realized that
there is a bit of freedom
in having a smaller audience.
So it was a huge struggle.
And my videos when I first left,
I think got a million views
each for like a couple months.
And I was like, "Oh, I
need to retain this."
And then very quickly, once
I think people realized
I didn't know what I was doing,
I had no goals for the channel.
I was like, "Each week, we'll
figure out something new
and I hope you watch it."
And I quickly (laughs) lost
this audience that I had
and realized that they
were not there just for me.
And it was a little bit
bit disappointing at first
'cause I thought, "Oh, I
guess I have the freedom
to do whatever," and I thought
that I had that with me.
And then it was a wake up call to realize,
oh, but you have to make good content.
You can't just expect them
to be there because it's you.
Egotistical maniac.
(hosts laugh)
And, you know, the views
I think got to about
like 30,000 to 60,000 views a video.
- Is this on the Anthony Padilla
channel?
- On the Anthony Padilla
channel.
- Really?
- Within the first year after.
- Wow.
- And at that time, you know,
if videos weren't getting 100,000 views
or even more, people in the comments
are just like, "Irrelevant,
irrelevant, wow, fell off,
fell off."
- It was views
plus ratio plus you fell off. (laughs)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, a lot of that.
- You basically had abandoned an audience
for a different style,
so then obviously that's gonna happen.
But people don't see it like that.
They're like, "Oh, your name
is worth so much."
- They're like,
"What do you mean you're
not doing sketches anymore?
I thought you were gonna do
your own sketches now," right?
- And I thought that I had
to, I thought it was beholden.
And I think the reason
that it got to that point
is I felt like I was
trapped in this idea of
I need to create sketches,
I need to be funny.
I need to deliver something
that appeases that audience
that I've learned how to appease.
And I think getting down to, you know,
I call them lower numbers, 30 to 60K,
I know a lotta people are up and coming,
and that is a great number.
- I mean, perspective wise,
that's low.
- I don't wanna discount that.
But at the same time,
I was like kinda floundering
around at that number.
And first of all, I had
to get outta my head
from looking at the numbers,
it wasn't about that anymore.
I realized that I had an opportunity now
to experiment without the
pressure of an audience.
So that's when I started experimenting
with all these different types of videos
and all these different types of things.
And that's when I fell into
doing I Spent a Day With videos.
And it was without that pressure.
And the first few did have that
pressure on me to be funny.
So I was kind of, you know,
I did I Spent a Day With Flat Earthers
and it was kinda like look how ridiculous,
how weird looking this is.
(all chattering)
These people are weird.
But slowly but surely,
over the next couple months
or half year, I started realizing
that I actually was really curious
about different types of people.
And I did this video I
Spent a Day With Furries
and I had a company help me
reach out to these people.
And I thought they were all local.
When they showed up, I
found out that one flew in
themselves on their own dime.
And then this person drove
three hours to be there.
- Geez.
- And I was like,
okay, this is, and I
already wasn't planning
to say like, "These people are weird."
But a part of me was like,
I don't understand this.
This is kind of a weird thing.
But, you know, they get
there and they're saying,
"I used to watch "Smosh" all the time,
I love your stuff."
- You're fucking weird.
(men laughing)
- So, anyway, why are you weird?
- So I very quickly changed my perspective
with the way that I went
into the interviews.
Like, there was no way,
and it felt weird to me doing
the flat earther episode,
it felt weird to me.
Like, I was going outside of my element
to give the snarky commentary
channel perspective
that was really popular
on YouTube at the time.
I realized I was kinda
falling into those tropes
that were so popular.
And I was like, I just feel
like I need to just be me
and have a conversation with
someone, be curious about them,
try to learn about their life.
And in doing so, afterward,
I had them reach out to me.
They were really excited
about the way it turned out.
But also a lot of
commenters were like, "Whoa,
this is the first time
I've ever seen furries
represented in a way where
they were treated with respect.
And that is so weird, I've
never seen that before.
I'm gonna send this to my
friends who don't understand me."
It was really then that I realized like,
oh, this is what actually feels right.
This doesn't feel, like, I'm
not appeasing an audience
I think I should be appeasing
'cause it's the trendiness
of YouTube at the time.
Or like this sense of humor
that I felt like I needed
to always like be this
character that I was on "Smosh."
I felt like I was able to
actually just be myself
and my editor then
helped me throw in jokes,
but it wasn't up to me anymore.
I was just making a
connection with that person.
- Back to like YouTube boomer talk.
- (laughs) Let's go. Let's go.
- You talked about, you
know, constantly learning,
constantly seeing what's out there.
There must have been a
point when you're just like,
I am so outta touch right now.
- Oh, for sure.
- 'Cause I constantly
feel that, sometimes
I'm like, I get YouTube.
I get the algorithm,
I get all the content,
I get what people wanna watch.
Sometimes you just see
something and you're like,
okay, I am a boomer.
- You see that one popular
video, and you're like, why?
Why this?
- Yeah, there's this
one channel called Weegeepie,
have you heard of that?
- No.
- Okay, so I don't know how they do it,
they have a 3D CG rig of Luigi
and they animate him and
his face to react to things.
Or at least this is what the
channel was a few years ago.
I don't know what they're doing now.
So he was reacting to things
with Luigi sound effects.
They're like, "Wow, whoa."
(hosts laugh)
And it was just like a
reaction channel by Luigi.
And I was like, and some of
them had millions of views,
and I was like, "This is so bizarre."
- (laughs) That sounds incredible.
- But I loved.
- That sounds incredible.
- I reached out, I
followed him on Twitter.
And I was like, "This shit,
keep it up, this shit's sick."
But it was so weird, and I was like,
there is always something
to learn about YouTube.
There's always some weird corner.
- I mean, now you're exploring that
as well.
- Yeah, now you're exploring,
yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah,
and those are the types of
people I really, really enjoy
talking to, where it's like this community
that's doing this thing that many people
would just think is bizarre.
Like, there's actually something to it.
And why does it catch on?
And we could talk about
the emotional aspects
of the connection that people make
and why do you think this is popular?
- I think it's just really
refreshing, you know,
I mean, obviously lately on the internet,
and even when you started
it, it was very combative
and everyone was always
at each other's throat.
And I think it just came out at the time
and kinda hit the right note of just like,
let's just talk, let's just see,
like learn about each other.
- Let's be open.
- Yeah, and I think it's,
yeah, I mean, the success,
I mean, it shows that the audiences
wanted that kind of content.
Like, people are curious
about all the types
of different things, be it pony,
pony-
- Pony players.
- In saying that-
- I wanna know that now.
I wanna know why.
- In saying that though, there
have been a couple of videos
I've seen from yours where
you do kinda bring back
that like old school, a little bit cynical
type of interviewer type thing.
Like, you know, the one
about like you interviewing
time travelers, for instance.
That one was a little like,
I saw like the little bit
of the cynical side of you,
which was just as entertaining.
- You have to be though.
- You have to be.
- That was right after
the flat earthers episode,
so I didn't quite detach
from that side of it.
But I feel like now if I
were to approach that again,
the topic that I'm like
a little bit like, mm,
I think I would just outright say
this seems completely unbelievable,
do you have people telling you that
and how do you feel about that?
And I feel like there's so many more
interesting conversations
to have about that.
- Mm.
- And I think a lotta people
are either afraid to tell
someone that their shit's whack.
Or all they wanna do is tell
them that their shit's whack
and they don't wanna hear
why they do what they do.
I think that if you
could just be transparent
with anyone really, if you
could just have a conversation
with anyone about why
they do what they do,
you can make some kind of a connection,
regardless of who the person
is, except Hitler, not Hitler.
(hosts laugh)
- Damn, they grow up so fast.
He's maturing.
- How'd you feel about TikTok?
'Cause if there's one thing
that does make me feel
like a boomer and outta touch,
it is just TikTok itself.
- Yeah, it's-
- Have you thought about
venturing into that?
- Oh, I have a TikTok channel.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I should really
have a TikTok.
- It does really well with just clips
from my interview series
cut down and-
- Yeah, we did that
as well for "Trash Taste."
- And does it work for you guys?
- Yeah.
- It works pretty well.
- I think that the thing about TikTok
is that there is an
audience for everything.
- Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
- So you might log on
and think this is fucking weird shit,
but then there is a corner of
the internet that is for you
on TikTok and their
algorithm is really good
at feeding you content eventually.
If you sift through enough
garbage for enough time,
it eventually will find
the thing that sits.
- Yeah, my favorite
category of TikTok videos
is somebody complaining about
something really specific.
And then someone's like,
"Hi, I'm the expert on that actually.
This is actually why it works."
And it's like, "Who is the toenail expert?
Why did you come to me?"
(men laugh)
- It's literally IOL Reddit, right?
- It is IOL Reddit.
- They'll be like,
"Toenail expert here,
let me explain to you."
- It's just like the
strangest experts all come out
and they're all good looking,
like that's the other thing,
everyone who is like
an expert on something
is just amazing looking.
- Yeah.
- There is always an
expert about everything.
- And they look amazing.
- And they always look amazing.
- It's like, why did you have
to be so good and charming?
Fuck.
- Did they become
good looking because they're an expert,
or which one came first?
- They became an expert,
then they had the time
to go and more out and
take care of themselves.
- Or is it that most people that look good
are bound to be experts?
- Yeah, maybe, maybe.
- It's like, I used
to be a model, and now
I'm a toenail expert.
(men laugh)
- It is really crazy, yeah,
but it's such a cool platform,
but it makes me feel really old.
- It is weird because I
thought it was gonna die.
- I think everyone, when it was bought,
when it was musically-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I thought it was
gonna go down the Vine route
back then.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Musically, it was the thing
and everyone was doing the musically,
like cringe, compilations.
Everyone just thought, oh, it's for kids.
And then TikTok blew up and
then, wow, everyone was wrong.
I think everyone thought it was gonna die.
- Yeah, yeah, when everyone was just like
that lip syncing or doing dances.
And you're just like, oh,
look at this funny thing
the kids are doing.
- The replies, man.
- Anthony was like, "I did
that so many years ago!"
- I built my career that way.
(hosts laugh)
They took my shit.
- I think it's the replies,
the replies and the ability
to share the music so easily
just was a game changer, I think.
And it made editing kind
of, you know, accessible
to the, I mean, editing
very accessible to beginners
and people who don't know it.
It's like, you just slide this
thing across, chop the video,
chuck it in, put this music over it,
and, oh, you want a funny filter?
We've got that too.
- True.
- So it kind of made it
more like less scary.
I mean, you open up like DaVinci Resolve
and you just have a panic attack.
You're like, what the fuck is this?
(Joey laughs)
Like, this makes no sense.
Adobe Premiere, it makes zero sense
if you don't watch five
hours of YouTube tutorials.
So I feel like it kind of
made it very accessible
in a way that kinda just worked.
- And TikTok is always
changing their shit.
If you look at TikTok
now versus a year ago,
it looks very different,
- Yeah, true.
- and before that,
and the features that they
add, they are doing the upkeep.
Vine, I mean,
(Connor laughs)
I think it was clear why
Vine died for many reasons.
One being that you
couldn't make money on it,
but also they were not keeping it up.
They were not updating it.
And fortunately or not,
things on the internet,
platforms need to constantly be updated
to go where people are wanting it to go.
'Cause it is ultimately for people, right?
- Instead Vine opted to be like,
what if we made a sequel to Vine.
- Vine Two.
- Let's make a Vine Two.
- Did they ever do that?
- No, no, no, no.
- Were those rumors, or were those legit?
- They kept saying it,
- They were legit.
- definitely, yeah.
- Yeah, Vine was like,
"We're coming back with Vine Two."
And people like were like-
- And then TikTok
was like, "Nah."
- Yeah, TikTok was like,
"Nah, we got this,
- Nah, we got this
square, man.
- don't worry."
- We got this, yeah.
- Well, I find it
really weird 'cause I feel like now TikTok
is what YouTube was like 10,
15 years ago, right?
- True, true.
- Where, you know, like
remember when back in the day
where YouTubers would try to get on TV,
which was like the old media,
in order to legitimize themselves.
And now it's like TikTokers
trying to become YouTubers
- Oh, for sure.
- in order
to legitimize themselves.
- To legitimize themselves.
- And it's been so weird just seeing
that transition, right?
- That's so true.
Yeah, I guess it's because the platform
is so easily accessible.
Like you were saying that
anyone could jump on there
and you can build an audience
on there, people can find you,
the algorithm is very good.
So it's basically like if
early YouTube had an algorithm
that fed people content that
was directly relevant to them.
- Yeah, and I think it's also
like the barrier for entry
for YouTube now, I feel like,
even though YouTuber is like,
you know, you can make anything on YouTube
and it'll be successful.
Still like the quality
of content on YouTube now
is so much higher than
it was 10, 15 years ago.
- Absolutely.
- We're in like the MrBeast era
where everything has to be $100,000.
I did this, I fucking stayed
up for one week straight.
It's like, "All right, okay,
I can't compete with that.
'Cause I just don't wanna do that."
- Have you seen any of
Ryan Trahan's stuff?
- I have, I have.
- Yeah, of course.
- So I feel like he's been reinventing
what YouTubers can now expect
to do with the platform,
because he's taking some
elements of the MrBeast style
with thumbnails that
look very nice and clean,
and he has an elevated
concept for this whole thing.
And it feels like a video game,
it feels like you're watching
this person's journey unfold
in front of you and you feel
like you can't click away
'cause you never know what's
gonna happen in any turn.
But yet it is still a vlog
and he can still, you know,
because it is a vlog where the whole idea
is that it's low produced,
he's able to make one a day.
- It's quite nice just watching it.
And you're like, this is like nice.
I just feel like it's not too crazy.
Like, you know, obviously,
- It's nostalgic.
- I love watching a
MrBeast video, but my God,
I feel like I'm a cog in a machine.
- Yes, yes, yes, absolutely.
- It's just so much.
- There's so much screaming and texting,
it feels like a refined, modernized vlog
that has kind of like an elevated
game plan.
- The thumbnails
are just next level.
- The thumbnails kill it.
And I never would've thought
that a vlog thumbnail,
which is not click bait,
'cause it's not click bait,
could look so good.
- Yeah, it's, I don't know
who does it but-
- Yeah, like I remember
when, you know, where
back when YouTuber vlogs
were just, you know, you
put on any digital camera,
hand handheld camera, and
then Casey Neistat came along
and just used a DSLR and made basically
like mini short films every day.
And people were like, "What,
you can do that, that's possible?"
And then everyone tried to
be Casey Neistat for a while.
- And then he burnt out.
- I mean, he was every day,
I mean, when he used to
talk about his schedule,
he was like, "Yeah, I'd wake up at 4:00 am
and I'm editing it on the plane."
I'm like, "What the fuck?"
- But I think what we can
learn from that experience
is that if you have something good,
you don't need to overdo it.
If you want it to have
any longevity, you know,
part of the game plan
is to figure out a way
for it not to take up your entire life.
You know, I interviewed
Markiplier and he was like,
"Burnout is when people
aren't refilling their bucket,
they're constantly
scooping outta their bucket
for their content, and
they're not refilling it
because they're not living
a life outside of that.
And you need to have that balance."
- Have you ever been burnt out?
- Yes, absolutely.
(hosts laugh)
- I would've been shocked if you said no.
- Just like, never, never.
Always a creative mind.
- 17 years strong, baby.
- I was trying to be polite,
the question shoulda been,
so when did you burn out? (laughs)
- You shoulda just said it,
honestly, you shoulda
just said it like that.
Many different times and every single time
is when I felt overworked.
And then once it became
like part of a company,
overworked, underappreciated.
It felt like I wasn't being,
like my opinions didn't quite
contribute to the creative.
But then also outside of that,
I was burnt out on my own
outside of "Smosh" after I left
and decided to do my own thing.
For a lot of that time, when
the views were dropping,
I was also burnt out, so it makes sense
that people were not
wanting to watch the content
of someone who was burnt the
fuck out by their own content.
That's like, that's not fun to watch.
There's a feeling you can
feel when someone is burnt out
by their content.
- Yeah, and then when
you go to the actual video
and the top comment is like,
"He's run out of ideas."
- Yeah, yeah,
I'm like, "Fuck you, dude,
I got so many ideas."
And then I just sit there and
I'm like, "I have no ideas.
Oh, fuck, they were right."
- Oh, shit. Call me out.
- But, you know, I think I
really started to reframe
what was important to me.
And then I started like
not taking it as seriously,
not putting as much of my time into it.
And I was able to live
a life outside of it
and have thoughts that
were separate from my work.
And I think that's when it
kind of helps reinvigorate
to a certain degree.
- Yeah, one thing
I was gonna ask is
like, because, you know,
compared to you YouTube
boomers right here,
we are very much children.
- Oh, yeah, nine years,
seven years right there.
- It's nine years,
seven years, yeah, like I just discovered
what boogers taste like.
(men laugh)
So it's like, what I wanted
to ask you specifically
is like, how much of longevity do you see
as a YouTuber being a career?
Right, because it's like, we
don't really have any like,
you know, 'cause instead of like Hollywood
or the acting industry
or music industry, right,
we already have examples of
people who have had careers
for like 30, 40, 50 years plus.
Right, but because YouTube
is such a new thing,
whereas I think the longest
is probably someone like you,
right, it's like, do you see yourself
doing this for the next
10, 15 years again?
- I mean, it's already been half my life.
So it feels like I can give
my confidence to the idea
that YouTube will be
around for a long time.
They haven't made any glaring mistakes
that are still glaring mistakes.
Like, it feels like they
made a ton of mistakes,
absolutely, I'm not gonna
write them off completely.
But it seems like over time
they are remedying a lot of those,
it feels like they actually
are caring about the community.
I'm not, you know,
there's plenty of issues,
but it seems like enough
people care to make changes
to keep the platform relevant.
- Right, yeah.
- 'Cause, it's like,
oh, go on, go on.
- Oh, no,
I completely lost my thought.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
- Just say, say, say.
- 'Cause, obviously,
people are gonna be
like, "What do you mean
they did this fucking thing?"
And it's like, I think,
as you were saying,
as a whole platform, I think they meant,
considering the amount of shit
that goes on the platform,
they do a pretty good job
at keeping it relevant,
pushing it forward and
making it the place.
Yeah, obviously, there's places
you can find that are better.
- Yeah, because I think
definitely like the
one moment that YouTube
did a fuckie wuckie and everyone was like,
"This is the end of YouTube,"
was when demonetization
became a thing, right?
Then apocalypse came and
everyone unanimous was like,
"This is it, this is where it dies."
But it somehow managed to
stick around for, what,
five extra years?
- I mean, that needed
to happen though, looking back at it,
it was an inevitability that
it was gonna come to something,
like a system like that was
gonna have to be put in place.
- They implemented a lot of things
that help with that though.
Like, on the backend, you
can upload a video now
and it'll say, I'm not
sure if it's for everyone,
I think it's for everyone,
(hosts laugh)
please correct me if I'm wrong.
I don't wanna be like-
(all chattering)
- I got YouTube privileges.
- You got YouTube privileges.
- I'm like, "YouTube's
great," and they're like,
"Bro, we do not have
any of those features."
- Well, let's find out.
- The 1%.
- Okay, so what I will say is,
when I upload a video, it says
checking on the monetization,
and then after a half hour,
45 minutes, an hour, whatever,
it eventually does like the initial check.
And then you can have some confidence
that it probably caught it
if it's gonna catch something
that you shouldn't have in the video.
So that has given me a lot of
confidence in the direction
of that, because monetization
was a huge issue.
Every time I'd upload
for a while, I was like,
"Uh, mm, I don't know,
let's see this thing
I put 10s of thousands of dollars into,
it might be worth nothing.
I could just be in the red for this."
Well, they did fix some things
I feel and they're slowly
but surely I think fixing a
lot of the glaring issues.
- Yeah, was there a point
where like this changed from,
you know, because as with the way
being a content creator is,
this changed from being a job to a career?
Because for the longest time,
I treated YouTube as a job
because you wake up and you're like,
"Maybe I'll be irrelevant
then, or tomorrow,
a week from now, a year."
And like, I didn't really
feel like this was a career
literally until this podcast.
When I'm just like, "Oh,
okay, this is like a business,
a sustainable business
that I can see myself
five, 10 years in the future."
Was there a point for that for you?
- I think the moment that
that changes with somebody
in general is probably
when you have a format
that you know you can come
back to and feel confident in.
And that's probably why
this podcast was like,
we know the format, we know,
yeah, you know it's kinda all figured out
so that it feels like
this is a repeating thing.
For me it was, (sighs) I think
it probably felt like career,
I mean, when we were purchased by Defy
because it was like we had
- Salary.
- salary.
I mean, I feel like it
was unique to me though.
But then after that, you
know, going off independently,
the moment that it felt
like a career for me now
was when I had a series I
Spent a Day With to go back to.
I knew that it was a repeating thing.
- Like a safety net, like
something comfort, you know?
- I think that's the difference,
when you know that you have something,
you're not starting from
square one every single video.
You know, a lotta people are
still trying to figure out
what they're doing, so every single video
is back to the drawing board.
And then that just feels like a job.
And trust me, it's tough.
- Yeah, because I feel
like when you're starting
off at YouTube, you
want to make every video
like a 10 outta 10 banger,
you wanna be motivated.
You wanna do something new every time.
Then you realize that after
a year or two of doing it,
you're like, this is
not sustainable at all.
I need some kinda formula
that I can fall back on
because I can't always be, you know,
at my peak of creativity every time.
- So you guys are like 90%,
probably going into each episode,
90% sure where things
are gonna go, you know?
And that-
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Yeah, well, going back to
the beginning of this episode,
right?
(men laugh)
- We know roughly, we know roughly.
- We know roughly, yeah.
- You know a little bit
about what the dynamic is
gonna be like at least.
- I know if I say this thing,
how maybe you'll react.
- You're face is not so sure.
Your face is not so sure.
(men laugh)
- I'm like, all I know is
that we're gonna have someone
on the show and we're gonna
be talking about their stuff.
- Well, you have a name
and you have sponsors.
- Yeah, exactly, exactly.
- Right?
- But-
- Yeah, I guess like,
sorry, what'd you wanna say?
- No, I was just saying like,
I feel like in a weird way,
we're still trying to figure out
that formula for "Trash Taste" in a sense.
It's like, we've kind of figured it out.
You know, it's obviously like a lot-
- 100 episodes deep.
(men laugh)
- Yeah, 100 episodes deep, right,
but it's like, I'm personally always like,
yeah, scared of like that
moment where it starts
to get repetitive or
starts to feel like a job.
And like, luckily, I don't feel
that way right now about it.
But it's like, I am
scared to fall into that.
- So what are you doing to prevent it
from feeling like it's a repetitive job?
- Ah, I mean, we're bringing
it on tour now. (laughs)
- I mean, we're filming overseas.
We're getting, you know, all
sorts of interesting guests
and stuff like that.
And I think the specials definitely help,
where that's the moment
where we can just really
explode with our creativity
in big ways.
- But also, I feel like
those specials probably are
what excite the audience
as well, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I hope so. (laughs)
- Hope so,
right, guys, right?
- Every now and then,
someone will be like,
"Where's our four hour conversation?
I wanted to go to work
and listen to four hours,
I don't wanna watch one hour of content."
(hosts laugh)
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I guess my final question is,
what do you wanna do in the future?
I mean, you've been on
the platform for 17 years,
is there-
- Are you gonna do something
for your 20th anniversary?
(Garnt laughs)
- Got nothing planned, man,
but 21st, you don't know.
(hosts laugh)
I think, I mean, I just wanna
continue refining what I do.
That's what I've been enjoying doing most.
This I Spent a Day With
series has been so fun for me
'cause every single episode,
I see at least one element
that I wanna refine.
Whether it's the lighting on the set
or something that's like
really technical like that.
Or it's like my performance on the intros,
it feels like I'm just reading words.
I'm gonna, you know, revamp
that and try to learn it.
Or like, I just went all
out and I did these tests
where I reshot some of my
intros where I have a jib,
which is like a fucking little
crane, glued to a camera.
And I was like, what if I,
'cause I was watching a bunch
of really big YouTubers,
you know, like Eric, for example.
And I was like, he has these intros
where he's choreographed this scene.
There's one that he did about like,
what would you do if you
had one day left to live?
So he starts off and it's
like the doctor saying,
"You have one day left to live."
And he's like in these bandages.
And then he's like, (inhales
sharply) he just gets up
and he gets out, and the doctor's like,
"Where are you going?"
And he's like ripping off
his bandages and stuff.
He's like talking to the
camera, and he's like,
"What would you do if you
had one day left to live?"
And he's like saying this
thing to the audience.
And he's bringing us through the camera,
it's like following him.
And it's like this choreographed scene
that just immediately
right off the bat you know
there was this effort that went into this.
This is a good setup for this video
'cause I know that if
the rest of this video
is anything like these first 30 seconds,
it's gonna be so much fun.
So I was like, how could I
apply some of these things
that I'm seeing modern YouTubers do,
and apply it to an interview format?
And I was like, well,
I can kinda choreograph
the way that I say these things.
So I'm still learning with that.
And so it's hard to say
like where I wanna go next.
But I think more importantly,
I know where I wanna go now.
And that's to constantly refine
and not allow myself to get bored
because I wanna always creatively
see what is like right
outta my comfort zone.
- It's pretty cool that
you've been on the YouTube
for that long, and you're like,
"I still wanna get inspiration
from the new guys."
- I was about to say
that's very humbling.
- Yeah,
it's inspiring to hear
that like you are still
on your journey, right?
After 17 years, you're
still on your journey
and you're still figuring stuff out.
- Yeah, because in my head, I was like,
"Damn, I've been doing
this shit for nine years,
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing."
(men laugh)
I'm glad to know
someone who's been doing
it for almost double that
also doesn't know.
- No, I'm just having fun, man.
It's like, if I enjoy what I'm doing,
I feel like that is the best
career that you could have.
- Yeah, definitely.
- Is where you enjoy it.
Not the career that, you
know, unfolds in this timeline
that I prebuilt in my
head for where it goes.
- You hear that, guys?
It's not about the money.
(men laugh)
It's about the love for it.
- Well, yeah, thank you
so much for coming on.
- Thank you, guys.
- This is awesome.
This is so cool.
- Hey, but look at all
these Patreons though.
- Yeah.
- You see all of them
on the screen.
- Oh, shit!
- Oh my God.
- Look at these Patreons
just coming down.
- Become a Patreon
immediately, this show is dope.
(hosts laugh)
Don't forget it.
- Who's your favorite Patreon?
I like that one.
- That one right there
in the middle, its already
gone, but I did enjoy it.
(men laugh)
- And, hey, if you'd
like to support the show,
go to our Patreon, patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also, follow us on Twitter,
send us some memes on the Subreddit.
And if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify.
And, yeah, go check out Anthony's stuff.
I don't need to tell you that.
(Garnt laughs)
Everyone should know.
- Yeah.
- Link in the description.
- Well, I hope we did
an okay job interviewing you for once.
- Oh my God, absolutely.
(Garnt laughs)
I've never done a three-on-one before.
(hosts laugh)
It's always been a one-on-three.
Thank you for putting me in
the reverse position, guys.
- Hopefully, we're gonna hear
about our skills later on,
you'll write it all down as a score.
- And I'll talk about this experience
on another episode of my show.
- Oh, shit.
- Oh.
- You won't know when it's coming.
(hosts laugh)
- You're just gonna
throw it in and be like,
"Oh, yeah, but, yeah,
so about the pony thing,
by the way, "Trash Taste" is shit."
- So, what, so I came in there,
and they didn't know anything.
They didn't know anything,
they weren't even prepared.
- You're such a better
guest than "Trash Taste,"
and they weren't even
guests, they were hosts, so.
(hosts laugh)
No, you guys are great.
- Hell yeah, dude.
- Thank you so much, man.
- I appreciate it.
- Thank you, guys.
- Well, thank you.
- And thanks for watching, guys.
- See you next one.
- [All] Bye!
(calm upbeat music)